bon bien monsieur le ministre
donc très très heureux de vous
accueillir pour cette audition qui est a
donc une audition budgétaire pour la
première application de la loi de
programmation militaire que nous avons
voté ici très très largement en juin en
juillet dernier juin dernier juillet
dernier je sais plus euh monsieur le
ministre avant d'en venir au au sujet
budgétaire du jour vous comprendrez que
je souhaite avec vous marquer un temps
sur les terribles événements qui sont
survenus depuis samedi en Israël et dans
la bande de Gaza le Sénat vient de
rendre un hommage appuyé en séance aux
victimes de cette effroyable attaque
terroriste dont plusieurs de nos
compatriotes euh ont perdu la vie donc
si vous en êtes d'accord je vous propose
en en mémoire un moment de recueillement
évidemment la mémoire des des victimes
de ce weekend merci
beaucoup
merci cette attaque dont je viens de de
parler pose aussi des questions en
matière de stabilité de l'ensemble de la
région et des questions de sécurité qui
nous concernent aussi nous nous
préoccupons aussi bien sûr du sort des
otages emmenés à Gaza dont sans doute
plusieurs de nos compatriotes et
monsieur le ministre il nous sera
précieux d'avoir votre analyse sur cet
événement terrible et sur ses
conséquences j'en reviens monsieur le
ministre sera notre travail de
préparation de la loi de finances la loi
de programmation militaire a fait
l'objet d'un accord des deux Chambres du
Parlement ce qui n'était pas acquis dès
le départ votre implication et la
qualité du dialogue que vous avez eu
avec le Sénat ont constitué deux Atou
pour arriver à ce résultat j'ai souvenir
de quelques nuits passer dans
l'émicycles parfois à Brenne pour
d'autres à discuter comment on dit le
bout de gras euh mais en tout cas ça
s'est toujours passé de la meilleure des
manières et je voudrais également saluer
je ne sais pas si est là mais
l'engagement de Christian Cambon dans
cette affaire qu'il a obtenu de
nombreuses améliorations du texte parmi
lesquelles une amélioration de la
trajectoire budgétaire pour laquelle
nous nous sommes tous largement battus
la prise en compte de nos préoccupations
a été importante pour nous convaincre de
voter cette loi en dépit évidemment de
toutes les interrogations que nous
avions mais que nous continuons parfois
d'avoir encore aujourd'hui cet accord du
Sénat sur la programmation militaire ne
signifie pas en effet que ce texte
suffira par lui-même à répondre à
l'ensemble des enjeux au auquel nous
sommes confrontés la situation
internationale est grave évidemment et
nous voyons bien la nécessité de
relancer l'effort de défense de notre
pays l'installation dans la durée de la
guerre en Ukraine le départ des forces
françaises du Niger les menaces qui
pèsent sur l'Arménie et depuis samedi
malheureusement la brutalité de
l'attaque terroriste qui que subit
Israël sont autant de signes du
caractère durable et polymorphe des
défis qui qui sont qui sont devant nous
nous avons donc besoin que la loi de
programmation militaire constitue un
socle sur lequel pourront venir s ATER
dans les années qui viennent de nouveaux
moyens notre rôle est à la fois de
défendre ce socle et de le consolider je
rappelle à cet égard que l'article 4 de
la loi de programmation prévoit je cite
que la trajectoire de ressources
budgétaires s'entend comme un minimum
nous veillerons à ce que le niveau de
l'effort national de défense atteigne
effectivement les 2 % du PIB en 2025 et
nous voulons préparer dès aujourd'hui
l'actualisation de la LPM qui devra
intervenir avant la fin de l'année 2027
nous serons donc très attentifs à vos
are présentation des ressources
budgétaires mais également extra
budgétaires pour 2024 afin de respecter
cet objectif nous prenons acte de
l'augmentation prévue par le PLF 2024 à
3,3 milliards d'euros des ressources
budgétaires de la mission défense par
rapport à la précédente loit de finance
conformément à l'accord que nous avons
trouvé sur la LPM il faut maintenant que
ces moyens supplémentaires permettent
d'améliorer la préparation
opérationnelle des militaires comme les
sénateurs et les députés l'ont souhaité
de concert est-ce que ce sera bien le
cas monsieur le ministre c'est une
question pour exercer notre mission nous
avons besoin de l'information du
Parlement que l'information du Parlement
pardon soit conforme au principes fixés
par la loi vous savez que nous avons eu
l'occasion dans un passé récent de
regretter le caractère insuffisamment
précis voire dilatoire des données qui
nous étaient fournies en particulier en
matière capacitaire la disponibilité
techniqueopérationnelle et les
indicateurs d'activité qui figuraient
dans le bleu budgetaire ont disparu on
on vient d'en échanger tous les deux
pendant quelques minutes et vous m'avez
vous avez pris quelques engagements et
nous nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
et vous m'avez communiqué ainsi qu'à mon
homologue de l'Assemblée nationale un
certain nombre d'informations nous
continuons à penser que ces éléments
sont utiles à la compréhension du
publicque et à notre mission
constitutionnelle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement voire d'alerte
en cas de difficulté nous espérons donc
que la mise en œuvre de la loi de
programmation mur inaugurera des
méthodes nouvelles et une plus grande
transparence à l'égard du Parlement je
sais que vous y êtes attaché et donc
nous y veillerons de même concernant
l'effort national de soutien à l'Ukraine
nous attendons de votre part monsieur le
ministre une évaluation sincère et
détaillé dans le cadre du CPLF et je
laisserai bien entendu nos rapporteurs
vous interroger précisément sur dans
quelques instances sur chacune de leurs
préoccupations
permettez-moi cependant de partager avec
vous trois interrogations pour en
revenir à la LPM l'arbre l'arme blindée
est redevenu un acteur essentiel des
conflits actuels le dialogue que nous
avons que nous entretenons avec notre
partenaire allemand est complexe est-ce
que vous pouvez nous assurer que vous ne
serez pas le ministre de la Défense qui
mettra un terme à la longue histoire du
savoir-faire français en matière de
construction de char en d'autres termes
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur le fait
que nous nous interdis nous ne nous
interdisons aucune option si le projet
de char franco-allemand ne devait pas
aboutir afin de conserver notre
souveraineté sur ce type de matériel
concernant l'aide que nous apportons à
l'Ukraine ensuite nous savons
aujourd'hui que ce conflit sera long et
que notre tride devra s'inscrire dans la
durée or les industriels de la défense
continuent de nous alerter sur le fait
qu'aucune commande significative n'est
passée afin de fournir l'Ukraine sans
avoir à puiser dans nos propres stocks
vous êtes qui à Kief vous nous en parlz
peut-être ou un autre une autre fois
mais euh monsieur le ministre avec de
nombreux industriels vous étiez en
déplacement afin de nouer des
partenariat industriel de long terme
est-ce que vous pourrez nous en dire
quelques mots et enfin nous devons
évoquer la décision annoncée par le
président de la République il y a 2
semaines de retirer d'ici la fin de
l'année nos 1500 militaires du Niger les
opérations sont en cours c'est une
nouvelle déconvenue évidemment et nous
sommes nombreux à avoir des
interrogations sur la stratégie suivie
et sur les déclarations successives
depuis le Poch intervenu dans ce pays
après après vous avoir donné la parole
je laisserai nos rapporteurs comme à
l'habitude budget rapporteurs budgétaire
vous interroger et nous aurons enfin des
questions de nos autres collègues et je
vous rappelle que cette audition est
captée et diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le le Président permettez-moi
d'abord de vous adresser mes
félicitations pour votre élection la
présidence de cette commission saluer
l'ensemble des nouveaux vice-présidents
secrétaire saluer l'ensemble des
nouveaux commissaires effectivement dans
une commission largement renouvelée et
puis tout simplement les nouveaux
sénateurs élus les sénateurs réélus au
terme du temps démocratique qui a
rassemblé les grands électeurs de la
série renouvelable de nos départements à
la fin du mois de septembre et je vaux
avoir une pensée particulière
effectivement pour le le travail du
Président Cambon comme vous l'avez fait
à l'instant puisque il m'a accueilli
comme comme jeune jeune ministre des
Armées et tout récemment nommé il y a
plus d'un an et demi et je pense que
nous avons réussi à créer un lien de
confiance entre la Commission et vous
l'avez rappeler je vous en remercie qui
nous permet d'avoir aussi beaucoup de
maturité démocratique dans la manière
dont le Parlement peut interagir sur les
thématiques régaliennes dont la défense
avec évidemment quelques enjeux parfois
qui touchent au secret enfin est une
grande démocratie et donc notre capacité
justement à associer les différentes
sensibilités politiques avoir un débat
de qualité éclairé dans lequel on le
sait tout n'est pas consensuel en tout
cas vous l'avez vu comme membre de la
commission mixte paritaire entre les
deux chambres par des sensibilités
politiques qui sont représenté à
l'Assemblée nationale euh les affaires
de défense national nont plus rien de
consensuel du tout et ça c'est quand
même évidemment un élément important
bonjour monsieur le sénateur folio euh
et donc je voulais évidemment vous
féliciter je reviendrai dans un instant
peut-être sur l'état
d'esprit qui peut augurer cette nouvelle
mandature de la commission puisque
désormais la loi de programmation
militaire est promulguée donc nous
rentrons dans un nouveau cycle de
contrôle d'exécution j'en dirai un mot
dans un instant peut-être que cette
audition budgétaire va avoir une
sensation à la fois de de déjà vu
puisque la la programmation militaire
est en toute fraîche par définition il
s'agit de porter
sur devant le Sénat le le ce qu'est
l'année N1 de la programmation pour
l'année 2024 et en même temps on sait
très très bien cette année N1 est
précieuse clé parce qu'elle est le
tuilage évidemment de la programmation
militaire précédente qu'elle dit quelque
chose aussi des éléments de stratégie
qui vont être développés qu'elle
permettre de rentrer dans l'art
d'exécution des différentes orientations
qui ont été retenues par les
parlementaires dans le cadre de cette
programmation et elle vient aussi
traduire au-delà des 3,3 milliards
d'euros en plus qui est quand même une
somme tout à fait considérable il faut
le rappeler puisque souvent on manipule
tous ces chiffres avec une banalisation
enfin qui rappelle quand même que
l'effort de la nation est tout à fait
redoutable en la matière et que donc
cette audition du jour d'après de la LPM
doit dire quelque chose et au fond
euh je pense monsieur le Président qu'on
va de plus en plus altern entre à la
fois une exécution la plus rigoureuse
possible de ce qui a été programmé et en
même temps une nécessaire introspection
et un débat intellectuel sur ce qu'il
convient non pas de déprogrammer pas
l'objectif mais d'adapter dans la
programmation vous avez cité vous-même
l'échéance de 2027 mais quelque chose me
dit que quand je vois là où nousous
sommes quittés pour la promulgation de
cette LPM le 14 juillet dernier
et la situation sécuritaire du monde qui
nous entoure au moment où je vous parle
pas tant que nous quittons le Sahel mais
que le Sahel est de nouveau au mise
d'une d'un risque terroriste absolument
majeur avec un risque immédiat quasiment
immédiat dans les semaines qui viennent
sur la sécurité du Mali avec une reprise
d'une activité terroriste qui est
absolument bouleversante et donc trop
peu de médias malheureusement se font
écho vous n'avez pas cité mais je sais
que vous êtes mobilisé sur le sujet
l'ensemble des groupes politiques au
Sénat les évidemment la situation en
Arménie la situation en Israël je rentre
d'Ukraine j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
on le voit bien euh le le monde dans
lequel nous allons déjà on le voit bien
ces 413 milliards d'euros étaient les
bienvenus pour faire taire celles et
ceux qui considéraient qu'il y avait
peut-être d'autres priorité que de nous
réarmer enfin faut faut le redire et
faut le réexpliquer devant nos
concitoyens mais au-delà même de cela on
voit bien la nature même des menaces des
sut technologiqu vont nous amener à
avoir une programmation qui sera
nécessairement vivante alors si elle est
vivante ça veut dire qu'il faut donc
qu'on ait de la méthode et moi je
considère au fond que les deux
commissions des deux assemblées
constitutionnelles sont l'endroit dans
lequel justement on pourra mener le
débat intellectuel soit de manière
publique soit peut-être de manière plus
plus privée mais pour nous permettre
justement d'adapter les choses il n'
demeure pas moins que la programmation
que je vous propose pour enfin la
présentation des crédits que je vous
propose est fidèle en tout point à la
programmation tel que vous l'avez voté
c'est plutôt rassurant puisque la
programmation militaire vient juste
d'être promulgué je vais peut-être en
faire une
présentation qui serait au fond de
rappeler ce qui convient d'être réparé
puisque la réparation n'est pas terminée
vous êtes revenu à de nombreuses
reprises donc j'en dirai un mot la
deuxième des choses qui nous avait
beaucoup mobilisé sur la cohérence
l'équilibre entre cohérence et masse et
je me permettrait peut-être de faire une
présentation qui soit moins technique
moins technocratique qu'elle accoutumé
et avec des cas pratiques de ce que les
état-majors mont proposé que j'ai validé
de faire pour l'année 2024 et le
troisème segment à mon avis le plus
important qui celui d'ailleurs peut
mobiliser la commission monsieur le
Président à moyen terme c'est évidemment
les nombreux sauts technologiques qui
s'imposent à nous tous et sur lequel al
la fois faut continuer de réparer ce qui
a été abîmé par le passé on y revient
pas on a déjà suffisment débattu et en
même temps faut commencer à largement
prendre date sur des segment nouveau sur
lequel j'en dirai un mot dans un instant
enfin on peut pas ne pas citer
intelligence artificielle quantique
cyberspatiale dont on voit bien que
évidemment tout cela tout cela être à
l'œuvre peut-être un mot j'ai déjà dit
du bien du président Cambon avant qu'il
n'arrive et donc je salue son
arrié je peut-être un mot sur ce qui a
été censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel puisque je m engagé
auprès du président Cambon et je me suis
engagé auprès de vous monsieur le
Président pin dans notre entretien au
préalable bon il se trouve que la France
insoumise a décidé de saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel c'était son droit le
plus strict que le Conseil
constitutionnel a estimé qu'un certain
nombre de dispositions étaient des
cavalier m'appartient pas en tant que
membre de l'exécutif de commenter cela
néanmoins un certain nombre de
dispositions ou d'orientations
politiquemitaire avait fait l'objet d'un
engagement de ma partengagement
politique au ban ou d'engagement avec le
président rapporteur bon et donc je
voulais aussi redire au début de cette
de cette audition euh ma disponibilité à
mettre en œuvre un certain nombre de de
d'engagement puisque c'est pas parce
qu'ils ne sont pas écrits dans la
programmation militaire que de gré à gré
entre nous on ne peut pas évidemment
organiser un certain nombre de choses
donc là évidemment je laisserai le soin
aux différents commissaires de nous
indiquer ce qui compte pour vous mais en
tout cas je je le sais notamment sur la
question d'exportation des armes qui é
un sujet qui a quand même fait l'objet
d'un débat nourri j'ai été auditionné
par avec deux autres ministres à
l'Assemblée nationale sur le rapport que
nous venons de de de remettre moi j'ai
réindiqué ma disponibilité pour mener la
même audition ici au Sénat voilà tous
ces points qui ont pu faire l'objet de
de censure non n' dem pas moi que
l'engagement politique que j'ai pris
devant les différents groupes sont des
engagements que j'entends tenir dans la
mesure où on a la base légale pour le
faire et parfois il y a pas besoin de
base légale c'est tout simplement de la
pratique politique de la volonté entre
le Parlement et le gouvernement et donc
je voulais le le le dire là pour
présenter peut-être les crédits pour
l'année prochaine et vous m'avez déjà
euh évidemment interrogé sur trois trois
sujets vous me direz comment vous
souhaitez que l'on que l'on organise
tout ça bon je pense qu'il y a quand
même un premier volet au-delà du fait
que à l'URE près la parole la
programmation est tenue non seulement
elle est tenue parce qu'on a bien les
plus 3,3 milliards mais enfin elle est
tenue aussi par les autres engagements
le fait que le SNU soit pas dedans le
fait que le traitement de l'inflation on
reviendra sans doute sur l'inflation une
fois de plus mais évidemment avec le
système de report de charge nous permet
de réguler un certain nombre de ses
effets que l'engagement est tenu parce
que l'aide à l'Ukraine n'est pas
ponctionné dans l'ensemble du du du
plafond bref tout tout ce qui avait été
dit globalement enfin c'est pas
globalement tout ce qui avait été dit et
évidemment tenu dans cette programmation
là donc ce qui est intéressant peut-être
la première série de de sujets que je
souhaite évoquer devant vous c'est
évidemment on voit bien que les
premières années de cette nouvelle
programmation vont être encore des
années de réparation d'un certain nombre
de fonctions de nos armées le premier
sujet puisque c'était un point que un
certain nombre de de sensibilités
politiques notamment les républicains
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
avaient porté devant nous c'est
évidemment la préparation opérationnelle
le groupe socialiste l'avait fait
également c'est la la préparation
opérationnelle de de nos armées euh
c'est intéressant de noter que sur la
marche de 3,3 milliards d'euros en plus
que vous avez voté pour l'année
prochaine sur ces 3,3 milliards d'euros
en plus mesames messieurs les sénateurs
vous avez 1,4 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires qui ne va aller qu'à la
préparation opérationnelle si on coupe
cette C somme en en plus petit morceau
c'est plus 324 millions d'euros sur
l'activité opérationnelle don le
carburant d'ailleurs c'est ça c'est très
intéressant et important et attendu plus
745 millions d'euros sur l'entretien
programmé du matériel terminologie plus
courante on pourrait parler de
maintenance c'est 305 millions d'euros
en plus sur l'environnement et la
cohérence traduction plus grand public
les munitions donc autant d'items qui
sont qui étaient attendus et qui vont
véritablement voir un changement
se poursuivre dans la vie des forces ça
veut dire que les cibles d'activité sont
tout en Haus et particulièrement dans
les secteurs qui étaient les plus éinés
des normes Cies ce qui m'amène
effectivement à repréciser un engagement
que j'ai pris devant vous que j'ai pris
devant le président gassillou
l'Assemblée nationale c'est
effectivement un certain nombre
d'indicateurs monsieur le Président ont
fait l'objet d'une d'une classification
partielle quand je dis partiel c'est que
elle continue d'être ouvert aux membres
du Parlement en tout cas aux membres de
cette commission comme comme la
commission de la Défense de l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai vu ici ou là notamment un
ancien parlementaire s'autoproclamant
expert un député je précise dans une
tribune récente
s'étouffant de cette décision j'ai envie
de lui répondre déjà il a participé
largement à l'abaissement des moyens
pour les armées donc considère que je
vois ça ça supplique comme une forme de
pardon et que la deuxième des choses
c'est que nous n'avons rien à cacher
puisque les indicateurs vont augmenter
néanmoins dans une ambiance au parfum de
guerre froide je fais attention à ce que
je dis mais dans lequel il y a une
compétition très forte entre les grandes
puissances il va s'en dire que avec la
DGA la DGSE et l'étatmajor des armées et
les trois armées nous avons
effectivement pris soin de rebalayer
l'ensemble des données qui étaient
publiques qui pouvaient être dans la
sphère publique et de se poser la
question si c'était bien raisonnable de
les garder dans cette sphère publique
pour cela on a regardé à se comparer
avec d'autres
démocraties je trouve que nous nous
étions peut-être plus transparents que
d'autres alors on peut s'en féliciter
mais enfin comme il se trouve aussi que
nous sommes un pays en proie à la menace
et que nous avons une armée d'emploi qui
est largement aussi sollicité sur
différents théâtres ou différents sujets
et il est clair que nous devons prendre
un certain nombre de mesures de
précaution pour autant il n'est pas
question que le Parlement euh voit ses
compétences affaiblir en la matière et
donc je vous ai communiqué les
différents eu indicateurs et évidemment
l'ensemble des rapporteurs enfin qui
vous souhaiterez monsieur le Président
et qui vous disignerez sont évidemment
complètement compétent pour le regarder
pardon je voulais dire ce point devant
vous puisque il vaut engagement pour la
suite évidemment de la relation entre le
gouvernement et le Sénat sur les
soutiens autre point important vous
étiez nombreux à vous être si mobilisé
sur le sujet je regardarde le sénateur
gario sur le sur le SCA madame la
sénatrice G sur le le SSA bon là aussi
la réparation continue globalement c'est
un budget total de 2,8 milliards d'euros
pour l'année prochaine c'est 275
millions d'euros euh en plus avec un
effort particulier sur les soutiens de
proximité si on prend le service de
santé des armées pour ne prendre que
celui-ci puisque demain on aura une
prise d'arme importante au valde grass
qui permettra de donner des perspectives
pour le SSA on voit bien qu'on a plus 33
% d'augmentation hors T2 c'estàd plus 70
millions d'euros qui va nous permettre
notamment de renforcer la capacité
hospitalière des antennes chirurgicales
de la livraison d'ambulance donc en fait
un certain nombre d'engagements
politiques qui ont été pris depuis
longtemps vont enfin trouver le leur
exécution par l'augmentation des crédits
les infrastructures là aussi un point
important c'est 2,3 milliards d'euros
pour 2024 c'est 270 millions d'euros de
plus 269 euh réparation mation des
infrastructures qui comprennent des
infras très militaires je donnerai des
exemples très concrès dans un instant
des infras plus civilo militaires le
logement de nos soldats tout simplement
sur lequel on sait qu'il y a beaucoup à
faire et beaucoup à à rattraper et donc
sur ces infras du quotidien notamment
avec une déconcentration des décisions
au plus près du terrain euh redonner du
pouvoir au chef de corps enfin autant de
sujets sur lequel je me suis exprimé
devant vous là évidemment on a des
moyens importants qui vont arriver et
puis enfin alors c'est pas tellement de
la
réparation mais la dissuasion nucléaire
puisqu'elle a fait quand même l'objet
d'un débat
important pendant la navette
parlementaire et que souvent aussi des
fausses informations circulle sur
celle-ci comme quoi au fond les 2 tiers
413 milliards NIR qu' la dissuasion
enfin des choses complètement aberrentes
ont circulé donc pour objectiver les
choses on a l'année prochaine plus 750
millions d'euros pour la modernisation
effectivement des composantes et je le
redis devant la commission de la défense
et des Affaires étrangères cela
s'explique pour une raison simple c'est
que au crédit classique d'entretien de
la dissuision annuelle que vous
connaissez vous avez également le début
des crédits de paiement qui arrivve pour
la modernisation des composantes à venir
pour la foste c'est évidemment les
sous-marins nucléaires lanceur d'engin
de 3e génération et pour les faces c'est
évidemment la
smpa et donc évidemment bah vous avez
Cees moments de tuilage mais comme
souvent tous les 20 ou 25 ans dans
lequel à la fois il faut financ financer
la dissuision du moment et en même temps
vous commencez à financer la dissuision
de dans 15 ou 20 ans et donc par
définition bah dans l'histoire de la
disoision si vous regardez les crédits
vous avez toujours des bosses et qu'on
va rentrer dans cette boss là qui est
identifié depuis maintenant plus de 10
ans en tout cas la fin du président
Sarkozi début du président Hollande avec
les décisions qui ont été prises et
qu'on le retrouve ici dans cette
trajectoire budgétaire puis enfin et je
sais que c'est un un point d'attention
important on avait parlé d'enseignement
de RETEX retour d'expérience de la
guerre en Ukraine sur un certain nombre
de contrats opérationnels ou de fonction
qui intéressent l'armée française et
notre territoire évidemment il s'agit
pas de se comparer à l'Ukraine je l'ai
aussi souvent dit devant vous mais 200
millions d'euros de plus pour les
munitions c'est 15 % de plus en
particulier pour la livraison de torpill
de missile Mistral de vlmica d'exo 7 de
missile MMP de but 155 mm enfin autant
de sujets sur lequels la RGPP du passé
les différentes contractions budgétaires
avaient conduit malheureusement à abîmer
un tout petit peu les choses comme vous
le savez là on a un effet et un effort
qui est évidemment visible et un point
important en AE un peu aussi en CP en
fonction des sujets sur la défense se
air vous vous rappelez que c'était aussi
un des points al de la lutte antidrone
cher au président pin jusqu'à au comment
dire aux couches les plus élevés et
l'année 2024 sera avec ce milliard
d'euros en commande euh un point
important pour les tourelles de 40 mm
surtout pour les 8 centé nouvelles
générations euh qui verront jour dans la
loi de programmation militaire je
regarde le rapporteur de la LPM euh et
donc là évidemment c'est l'année
prochaine que nous allons lancer tout
cela avec quand même des crédits de
paiement et des livraisons dans les
armées de manière plus immédiate avec de
systèmes de vlmik et d'un lot de missile
Mistral sur la fidélisation autre thème
euh pour parler un peu quand même de
Ressources Humaines je je fais des
allers-retours mais euh partie quand
même faitussi l'objet de réparation faut
faut faut faut se le dire euh 2024 c'est
une année importante parce que c'est
l'année charnière de la mise en œuvre de
la nouvelle politique de rémunération
des militaires avec des sommes
importantes que vous avez voté hein
c'est 351 millions d'euros en année
pleine donc 263 millions d'euros pour la
3ème marche qui va rentrer en vigueur là
ce mois-ci ça veut dire qu'à la fin de
ce mois vous aurez sur la solde de nos
soldats un effet significativement à la
hausse je suis toujours le même exemple
la prime du combattant terrestre pour
l'armée de terre là on est véritablement
sur le début euh enfin le début on est
pas dans le début mais on est sur la
visibilité maximale en pouvoir d'achat
pour nos soldats sur la la nouvelle
politique de rémunération des des
militaires vous avez en 2024 plusieurs
rendez-vous c'est l'année de la mise en
œuvre des mesures indiciaires pour les
sous-officiers conforme au cadancement
de la LPM là aussi qui avait été voté
11,5 million d'euros à partir d'octobre
prochain après on sera à 46 millions
d'euros en année pleine je vous rappelle
que c'est un point important de
redyamiser les grilles indiciaires des
sous-officiers pour que les militaires
durant a un intérêt à devenir
sous-officiers c'est l'attractivité du
premer grade de second maître et de
sergent évidemment dont il est question
et puis vous avez en 2024 l'année mise
en œuvre de l'ensemble des mesures
interministèr
pratiquement 300 millions d'euros qui
sont au fond les risations du point
d'indice mais aussi les garanties
individuelles de pouvoir d'achat et les
risation du SMIC qui évidemment concerne
l'ensemble de la fonction publique enfin
les militaires sont aussi des agents
évidemment de l'État et donc ils sont
concernés par par cette affaire
peut-être un point c'est la nouveauté
enfin la nouveauté relative puisque je
vous l'avais annoncé en transparence
mais la mesure de l'article 6 de la LPM
qui permet de transformer des ETP en
mesure euh d'attractivité pour les
militaires euh était une mesure qui
était attendue enfin qui était en tout
cas souhaitée par tout le monde et donc
on va la mettre en uvre dès 2024
puisqu'on sait très bien que l'ensemble
des cibles ne seront pas forcément
rempli pour des raisons que j'avais déjà
indiqué devant le scénar mais enfin
peut-être qu' C de nouveaux commissaires
voudront poser des questions là-dessus
je suis à votre disposition mais
globalement cette la mise en œuvre
l'activation de cette clause va nous
permettre de de déclencher 76 millions
d'euros euh de mesures d'attractivité
donc 41 million d'euros pour fidéliser
dans les métiers en tension euh parce
queune fois plus regarder cette affaire
de manière globale n'a pas de sens ce
qui est intéressant c'est de la regarder
là on a des difficultés c'est évidemment
sur le numérique c'est évidemment sur le
service de santé des armées où une
enveloppe exceptionnelle de 6,5 million
d'euros va être développée les
ingénieurs civile de la défense les
ouvriers d'État la filière renseignement
ou la filière sociale un mot sur le plan
famille euh là aussi c'était attendu par
la troupe 750 et les civils de la
défense 750 millions d'euros sur la le
programmation militaire c'est 70
millions d'euros pour l'année 2024 c'est
donc pratiquement 25 millions d'euros de
plus par rapport à l'année précédente on
a souvent tous été élus locaux on l'
encore en tout cas à la tête d'exécutifs
locaux dans cette dans cette commission
on sait très bien que là pour le coup
c'est des choses très concrète en
matière de place en crèche notamment qui
est le point le plus le plus urgent me
semble-t-il à traiter mais c'est vrai
aussi en matière d'hébergement je
pourrai là aussi y revenir deuxème série
de remarques pour être complet euh on a
souvent parler cohérence masse pendant
nos discussions le son d'Orion capacité
à mener des contrats opérationnels euh
au fond en 2024 on va essayer d'avancer
comme un
tout comme un tout c'est à la fois la
livraison d'équipement majeur j'aurais
pu commencer par là mais volontairement
je l'ai pas fait c'est tout de même une
année dans lequelle on verra 13 rafales
issus des r complètement être livré un
sous-marin nucléire d'attaque dans la
poursuite évidemment de ce qui a été
fait par le le sufrin avec le sufrin
pardon une fris de défense et
d'intervention 138 véhicules blind des
griffons 103 véhicules blind des
cervales bref l'ensemble et là souvent
c'est les livraisons d'ailleurs de la
LPM précédente évidemment que l'on que
l'on voit alors qui crée quand même des
crédits de paiement en 23 et en 24 cela
va s'en dire enfin on a bien évidemment
la conduite de renouvellement du parc la
deuxième des choses je le disais la
préparation opérationnelle plus 1,4
milliards d'euros j'en ai déjà parlé
mais c'est important parce que ça ne
sert à rien d'avoir des nouveaux
équipements si en face vous avez pas
l'activité qui qui va avec donc là on a
bien le début de mise en cohérence et
puis la troisème des choses j'en ai un
peu parlé la Haus des effectifs si
certes on fait notre deuil d'une partie
de la réussite euh du recrutement je le
redis pas pour des raisons budgétaires
mais pour des raisons tout simplement de
conduite du de ce recrutement on va vers
une augmentation de plus 456 ETP l'année
prochaine avec un ciblage clairement
assumé ENF des secteurs prioritaires les
soutiens 140 personnes le renseignement
63 personnes le cyber 55 personnes les
capacités majeures d'armée le
renforcement outremer plus 55 personnes
ou encore le numérique plus 48 personnes
la montée en puissance de la réserve qui
fait partie de notre modèle aussi je
répondrai sans doute à vos questions on
est sur une chronique que le Parlement a
souhaité de plus 3800 effectifs pour
l'année prochaine nous verrons bien
comment on arrivera à les remplir en
tout cas je pourrais vous donner
quelques indications sur le sujet je
veux pas être trop long et puis la
remontée en puissance sur les soutiens
et les infrastructures bon je vais
essayer de vous donner désormais
quelques exemples par armée de ce que ça
veut dire en voyageant un peu au quatre
coins du pays parce que je pense que
c'est intéressant et vous allez amené
dans le mandat de cette commission à
vous déplacer au contact des forces et
donc de voir aussi ce que les différents
états-majors ont préparer et ont ont
souhaitait en tout cas ce que je leur ai
demandé de préparer ce que j'ai validé
si on veut illustrer de manière très
pratique la cohérence si on va par
exemple à montauan dans l'armée de terre
et qu'on veut avoir un exemple au 17e
régiment du génie parachutiste on voit
qu'on va avoir en équipement la
livraison de 29 cervales dans ce Ré en
2024 ça va s'accompagner en même temps
d'une livraison parallèle des
infrastructures de stockage et de MCO
des cales alors quand on le dit comme ça
on se dit ce sont des hangars non ce
sont des hangars à forte valeur ajoutée
technologique on parle typiquement d'un
chantier de 30 million d'euros une fois
plus on a tous é élus locaux donc on
voit globalement en comparaison ce que
ça peut vouloir dire sur le terrain des
infrastructures et puis c'est pas le
tout d'avoir des Serval qui arrive avec
les infras si vous n'avez pas
l'entraînement et l'activité qui va avec
typiquement on sera sur une cible à 90
par équipage c'est-à-dire une hausse de
20 % en terme d'activité pour cette
force par rapport à l'entraînement qui a
été fait sur les VAB en 2023 là vous
avez bien une illustration cohérence
mass dans lequel on pousse les
interrupteurs sur l'ensemble des items
pour que faire en sorte que tout ça ait
un effet opérationnel 5e régiment de
dragon à macamp réception des trois
premiers chars Lecler rénovés à mai
l'année prochaine vous vous rappelez une
cible à 21 pour l'armée de terre en 2024
en même temps livraison d'un bâtiment
dédié à l'instruction avec des salles de
for tion tactique et technique là aussi
un chantier de 11 million d'euros et en
même temps les munitions qui vont avec
puisque ça sert à rien d'avoir le char
sans ces munitions en 2024 c'est plus
10000 auut de char c'est la première
tranche de la commande de 90000 obus sur
la LPM et là en revanche on aura un
entraînement qui va augmenter peut-être
de manière plus saccadée puisque
évidemment c'est le rythme de la
rénovation àivie du Lecler qui fera
aussi la disponibilité du matériel sur
lequel nos soldats nos cavaliers en tout
cas pourront le faire aérocombat 3è
régiment d'hélicoptère de combat à
éteint livraison de de NH90 en même
temps posuse la première pa des
infrastructures opérationnelles pour le
NH 90 pour son MCO pour son stockage
pour l'ensemble du régiment et 5 heur de
vol en plus à l'entraînement pour chaque
équipage de NH90 par rapport à l'année
2023 là aussi un bon exemple de la
cohérence de ce qui est fait et avec cet
effet toujours délétaire d'avoir vu
parfois du matériel neuf arriver mais de
ne pas avoir les crédit pour le faire
fonctionner et donc là aussi je veux que
cette LPM soit pour le coup une rupture
en la matière et nous permett de
regagner des capacités opérationnelles
euh je me dois d'être interarmé euh
évidemment pour des raisons
diplomatiques donc l'Armée de l'Air et
de l'Espace euh avec l'aviation de
combat euh création du 5e escadron
rafale d'orange là aussi livraison de 13
rafales pour l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace c'est donc plus 40 % sur les
munitions simples une tonne 1 demi-tonne
250 kg au bus c'est des missiles
météores qui sont commandés et puis si
vous faites venir la nouvelle génération
de Rafale par définition euh il faut que
la piste d'or soit entièrement refaite
fait et livré la bonne année
c'est-à-dire en 2024 que tout
l'écosystème Rafal soit livré là aussi
la bonne année escadron atelier bâtiment
simulateur l'autre fonctionnement pour
l'escadron c'est 84 millions d'euros
pour la seule base aérienne d'orange
donc quand on commence à territorialiser
les sommes on s'aperçoit quand même que
c'est redoutablement important et vous
l'aviez demandé donc c'est donc
satisfait avec pour chaque pilote de
Rafale euh une une comment dire une
dotation de 13 he de vol supplémentaire
en 2024 c'est 10 % d'augmentation par
rapport à 2023 là aussi c'est c'est un
bon exemple si on était diplomate euh si
on a parlé d'aviation de chasse faut
parler d'aviation de transport donc je
vous propose d'aller à Orléan avec la
livraison de 2 à 400 m sur la base
aérienne d'Orléan pour l'année 2024 mais
en même temps on a besoin de la
livraison de la piste sommaire qui est
en fait une piste qui permet de faire
des entraînements en conditions comme on
peut parfois le connaître en OPEX par
exemple en Afrique et puis
l'entraînement qui va avec avec là aussi
21 he de vol supplémentaire en 2024
c'est-à-dire là aussi 10 % de de de
volume horaire d'entraînement en plus
pour les aviateurs sur le transport par
rapport à l'année 2023 c'est un exemple
marine national guerre des mines sujet
bien connu dans cette commission
première capacité dronisé en 2024 à
Brest euh trois premiers modules de
drones constitués chacune d'un drone de
surface d'un robot sous-marin et d'un
sonard le 4e en 2025 les infrastructures
qui vont avec livraison du hangar et
bâtiment tertiire avec le
centraleopération évidemment
l'entraînement des trois équipages qui
sont formé avec les téléopérateurs de
drone avec les différents retours
d'expérience des prototypes et puis bien
sûr derrière de manière incrémentale des
commandes de drones sous-marins de
quatre modules de drones supplémentaires
et un premier lot de quatre bâtiments de
Gard des mines pour lequel comme vous le
savez j'ai signé avec les homologues
belges et néerlandais là aussi une
stratégie commune pareil pour
l'outre-mer livraison d'apatrouilleur
outr-mer en Polynésie française pardon
monsieur le sénateur de pas prendre un
exemple calédonien mais je pourrais y
revenir des infrastructures bah la
construction du d'accueil pour les deux
patrouilleurs c'est pratiquement 17
millions d'euros et l'entraînement c'est
95 jours de mer prévu pour l'équipage
après une rupture temporaire de capacité
sur le segment patrouilleur comme vous
le savez pendant quelques temps je
pourrais continuer comme cela mais
l'idée c'est que à chaque fois on
avancera justement sur ce trépied
entraînement munition MCO infra tout ça
en même temps et évidemment le le la
question de l'équipement qui qui va en
face dernier point j'en termine par là
pardon d'avoir été un peu long euh
évidemment c'est mon obsession depuis
cette rentrée même depuis la discussion
de la programmation militaire c'est de
de de prendre date pour l'avenir sur ce
que va être la guerre de demain et ça ça
a été aussi un des choix y compris sur
les cibles de matériel tel que je vous
les ai proposé et dans la conduite des
différentes opérations qui correspond
aux menaces qui peuvent réellement peser
sur la nation française ou en tout cas
sur ses intérêts de par le monde il est
clair que la part de innovation dans
cette LPM est importante les ruptures
technologiques on le voit bien sont très
brutales et au fond on se doit d'avancer
vite c'est vrai du spatial vous avez 600
millions d'euros pour l'espace en 2024
avec la livraison d'un satellite
d'observation CSO 57 stations cracuse 4
et puis on va avoir des engagements des
commandes importantes en 2024
pratiquement 15 milliards d'euros
d'engagement principalement sur le
programme ares vous connaissez déjà tous
ces programmes je les avais détaillés
devant vous 430 millions d'euros pour
les drones et les robots plus 130
millions d'euros c'est 43 % de plus que
l'année précédente là pour le coup on a
véritablement un effet
LPM nouvel LPM qui se qui se ressent
c'est évidemment ce que je viens
d'indiquer sur les les huit drones
sous-marins et évidemment les quatre
drones SDT que une fois plus le
président de la commission connaît bien
en tout cas là on a bien le pivot sur
les drones qui est en train de se faire
on pourra là aussi revenir 330 million
d'euros sur le cyber plus 800 millions
d'euros par rapport à l'année précédente
là c'est l'achat de chiffre radio pour
l'ut temp enfin compatible auut temp
pardon des travaux sur la mobilité
sécurisé et puis à ces crédit se rajoute
les 55 et l'équivalent temp plein que je
vous ai décrit évidemment tout à l'heure
500 millions d'euros de plus pour le
renseignement euh c'est une somme
importante 500 million d'euros en tout
pardon pour le renseignement plus 40
millions d'euros pardon c'est une somme
importante pour l'année 2024 425
millions d'euros pour la seule DG se 51
million d'euros pour la drsd 65 millions
d'euros pour la DRM avec là aussi des
augmentations d'effectifs et à cela se
rajoute évidemment un nombre de crédit
sur les ruptures
technologiques intelligence artificielle
quantique sur lequel là aussi on pourra
y revenir je ne traite pas
volontairement monsieur le Président
d'autres sujets pour ne pas être trop
long lien armé nation mais la secrétaire
d'État tvau ou mirales pourrait le faire
la mission ancien combattant dont j'ai
la responsabilité ité mais dont la
secrétaire d'État pourra le cas échéant
la défendre devant vous les sujets liés
au blessés aux maisons atthos au
rendez-vous aussi de 2024 les Jeux
olympiques mais aussi le 80e
anniversaire de la libération de notre
pays c'est vrai des débarquements de
Normandie mais aussi de Provence et de
tout ce qui s'en suit qui sont
évidemment aussi des points d'actualité
qui ne sont pas sans lien avec le budget
du ministère pour l'année prochaine
pardon d'avoir été long mais je l'espère
complet et peut-être que je garde vos
trois interrogations en renvoi de ce qui
peut-être dit par vos collègues monsieur
le Président très bien monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup donc on va
procéder comme à l'accoutumée donc les
rapports de la mission défense donc on
va commencer par la programme p144
environnement et prospective et et
prospective de la politique de défense
donc c'est Pascal Alizard et Gisel
Jourdin donc je laisse la parole à
Pascal Alizard oui monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le ministre je suis
chargé d'excuser l'absence de ma
collègue Giselle jourd je vais donc
donner lecture de sa question votre
audition monsieur le ministre est donc
l'occasion de vous poser une première
question et qui correspond à mon premier
contact avec cette matière sur laquelle
il n'est pas toujours facile de répondre
je pense à l'action de nos services et
en particulier aux leçons que nous
pourrions retirer des événements qui ont
conduit au retrait de la France du Mali
puis du Burkina Faso et d'ici la fin de
l'année du Niger j'ai moi même
écrit-elle participer l'an dernier à une
mission de notre commission dans le Golf
de Guinée et je dois dire ma
préoccupation sur l'instabilité de cette
région et ses conséquences sur la
pérennité de nos forces prépositionnées
au Sénégal en Côte d'Ivoire Gabon et
Djibouti monsieur le ministre que
pouvez-vous nous dire ici sur
l'efficacité de nos services en matière
d'anticipation comment allez-vous en
tirer conséquence en terme de
réorganisation de nos moyens budgétaires
humains et technologiques voilà la
question de de la sénatrice Giselle
Jourda je rajouterai d'ailleurs
puisqu'elle parle de
l'évacuation du Niger pouvez-vous nous
donner une idée du calendrier puisqu'on
entend parler de la fin de l'année mais
on entend dire aussi que des opérations
sont en cours ou
imminentes voilà et j'en viens à ma
propre question si vous le voulez bien
pardon les crédits consacrés aux études
àontt seront quasi stables en 2024 1
Millard 17 million d'euros contre 1ard
16 millions en
2023 hors dissuision ces moyens
connaîtront donc une baisse de l'ordre
de 15 millions passant de 809 à 795
millions comment justifiez-vous cette
petite diminution mais néanmoins
diminution au regard des besoins
identifiés dans la LPM dont vous parlez
et notamment en matière
d'hypervélocité d'intelligence
artificielle ou de cantique par exemple
vous avez quasiment abordé ces sujets
dans votre propos liminaire et 2e
question toujours sur le programme 144
qui porte la contribution versée au
gouvernement de Djibouti au titre de
l'implantation de nos forces permanentes
françaises sur son territoire 26,5
million d'euros soit 400 oui 04 million
d'euros pardon 400000 € supplémentaires
par rapport à 2023 le traité de
coopération avec Djibouti est
actuellement en cours de renégociation
et je voudrais rappeler l'importance
stratégique de conserver ce partenariat
de défense avec Djibouti monsieur le
ministre pourriez-vous nous faire un
point sur l'état d'avancement des
discussion et quels sont les attendus de
part et d'autrre
merci merci Pascal juste pour compléter
peut-être pour nos collègues qui
viennent d'arriver donc les crédit am
mon c'est 1 milliard d'euros par an et
qui concerne essentiellement euh des
crédits de des financements pour euh le
je dire l'innovation et puis le
développement technologique de nos
entreprise notamment juste pour
compléter ce que disait Pascal parce que
je j'ai volontairement pas posé de
questions sur Cees sujets avant est-ce
que vous pourrez nous dire quelques mots
sur euh ce que nous avons voté dans le
cadre de la LPM sur le le le fléchage
d'un certain nombre de crédit amont vous
parliez de 10 % mais on avait pas fléché
je crois de bon temps vers les euh PME
ETI euh comment est-ce que ça va se
mettre en place
merci
comme vous le souhaitez euh ce qui me
permet de de revenir d'abord sur vos
trois interrogations initiales puisque
le nigè évidemment est est est commune
euh bon sur le sur le Niger pour le
calendrier
euh les opérations de de de rapatriment
ont démarré euh elle se passe
correctement à ce stade euh
elles vont mon avis prendre plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois d'où
l'indication qui a été donné jusqu'à la
fin de l'année puisque il y a une
manœuvre logistique qui évidemment assez
complexe prendre soin évidemment des
hommes et des femmes mais aussi du
matériel que un certain nombre
d'acheminements se font pour certains
matériel uniquement par voie terrestre
et que tout ça va évidemment prendre du
temps c'est une audition budgétaire vous
ne m'avez pas posé la question mais tout
ça va aussi coûter un peu d'argent
puisque par définition quand du matériel
rentre du C il a aussi vocation à être
remis en condition opérationnelle la
manœuvre logistique en tant que telle
évidemment coûte aussi un peu de un peu
d'argent sur la question sur le Sahel et
les services al j'ai j'ai l'occasion
d'aller très loin dans mon propos devant
la délégation parlementaire pour le
renseignement gage à ce que les
discussions de la DPR restent au sein de
la DPR je le dis puisque j'ai été un peu
étonné récemment de voir dans la presse
quelques fuite néanmoins ce que je peux
dire dans cette audition qui est
retransmise c'est que la DGSE comme
d'ailleurs la DRM ou la drsd en tout cas
les trois services dont j'assure la
tutelle n'ont pas failli sur la
situation au Sahel on peut je l'assume
très directement qu'est-ce qu'il y a à
constater la première des choses c'est
évidemment euh l'activité terroriste et
c'est ce pourquoi nous étions là-bas
beaucoup de commentaires ici ou là
voudrait recréer un un mauvais mobile
aux choix qui ont été fait tant par le
président Hollande que par le président
Macron enfin c'est parce qu'il y avait
une activité terroriste importante que
nous avons été appelés au Mali et
d'ailleurs aussi au Niger et que nous
étions dans une position de combattre au
côté des forces armées local de faire de
ce qu'on appelle de l'appui au combat
donc il est clair que les services ont
évidemment mené un travail très
important très important de détection de
cellules terroristes de reconstitution
d'organigram des groupes terroristes qui
sont quand même sur une zone
géographique immense on finit aussi par
avoir des problèmes de vue dans la
manière de de de projeter les choses
enfin l'ensemble du Sahel constitue une
surface gigantesque des groupes
terroristes qui en plus sont divisés
entre eux parfois des agendas politiques
euh propres euh en fonction de tout un
tas de de critères qui méritent une
analyse poussée il est clair que les
services de renseignement DRM et DGSE
mais aussi un peu les drsd ont largement
été mobilisés pour se faire et
qu'évidemment
euh c'était aussi pour la sécurité du
partenaire qui nous accueille après je
vois bien ce qui a été écrit ici ou là
dans la presse cet été euh notamment au
mois d'août en disant euh on n'a pas vu
le le le coup d'État arriver c'est pas
vrai enfin je veux dire il y a déjà eu
des tentatives de coup d'état contre le
président Bazou que le président Bazou
je peux le dire je je je l'ai fait
moi-même lorsqu'il m'a reçu euh poser
des questions sur sa sécurité sur euh
éventuellement euh les euh comment dire
euh les différents protagonistes qui
pouvaient attenter justement soit à sa
vie soit à l'ordre constitutionnel du
pays mais le président Bazou est un
grand
leader je le dis parce que il m'a
fondamentalement impressionné quiconque
d'ailleurs l'ayant rencontré a pu être
impressionné par la qualité de cet homme
son honnêteté sa hauteur de vue et que
le président Bazou est allé au
risque je pense qu'il faut qu'on lui
rende aussi c hmage que il savait que
dans son entourage malheureusement le
risque existait donc c'est pas la
faillite d'un service français c'est le
c'est un homme un homme d'État qui en
connaissance de cause est allé jusqu'à
connaître la captivité qu'il connaît
aujourd'hui devant la DPR je suis allé
beaucoup plus loin et beaucoup plus
précisément sur les sujets je
m'arrêterai donc là mais j'ai informé le
Parlement par ailleurs et donc je ne je
je ne enfin n'y a pas eu de défaillance
des services français sur ce qui s'est
passé au sel je pense qu'il faut le dire
très clairement la vraie actualité du
Sahel va être désormais évidemment la
résurgence massive du risque terroriste
massive
quand je dis massive
c'est
potentiellement se retrouver dans une
situation dans lequelle il pourrait y
avoir une partition du Mali dans les
semaines dans les mois qui viennent donc
nous remettre dans une situation qui
serait celle au fond avant que le
président Hollande ne prenne la décision
de lancer Serval puis Barc c'est une
réalité qu'il faut regarder c'est pas la
faute de la France contrairement à ce
que certains racontent je ve dire je
crois que moi je l'ai dit de nombreuses
reprises l'occasion d'IR parler avec le
président hand il y a pas très longtemps
tout ça ce sont Bonn décisions ont été
prises enfin la réalité c'est que les
Maliens ont fait le choix de préférer
Wagner pas les Maliens non pas pas les
malien la jeinte Malienne pardonnez-moi
parce que les Maliens sont les premières
victimes de ce qui se passe la jeinte
Malienne a fait le choix de de de
préserver son
pouvoir et ses avantages en ayant
recours à Wagner plutôt qu'à l'armée
française si je vais plus loin devant
votre commission beaucoup considéent
c'était donc le problème de la France
que de la France je
note voilà Monsieur le Ministre
j'appelle mes collègues rapporteurs y
compris à la synthèse ouais et et vous
avez le droit d'appeler le ministre
aussi à la synthèse parisque je suis un
peu long dans mes dans mes dans mes
réponses donc je vais essayer de d'être
plus plus rapide euh Arménie c'est un
sujet que je que je suis de très près
pas de manière très vocale en matière de
communication puisque j'estime que c'est
évidemment le canal Affaires étrangères
qui doit dominer enfin j'ai établi une
relation de confiance avec le ministre
de la Défense d'Arménie euh il y avait
une demande ancienne que vous connaissez
qui était l'ouverture d'une mission de
défense permanente le ministre Lemoine
connaît bien le dossier euh le la
mission de défense a été ouverte je note
d'ailleurs que notre attaché de défense
lieutenant colonel expérimenté fait
l'objet d'attaque dans le champ
informationnel euh donc j'en conclu que
j'en conclu que tout ça produit un effet
positif puisqu'il est pris pour SIM
enfin devant vous je tiens vraiment à le
féliciter pour son engagement et et le
travail qu'il va accomplir ça a été dit
effectivement par le chef de l'État on
peut avoir un agenda en matière de de
défensif euh
tourner autour de vente d'armes pour
être tout à fait clair puisque c'est ce
que c'est c'est le l'objet la nature en
tout cas des discussions que nous avion
avec avec l'Arménie j'en dirai pas plus
sur quelles armes puisque tout ça
évidemment peut faire l'objet après de
pression divers et variés je pense qu'il
faut qu'on se donne quelques quelques
quelques Chan effectivement que tout ça
fonctionne en tout cas vous voyez bien
que certaines armes sont strictement
défensive ne peuvent en aucun cas faire
l'objet d'un détournement à à d'autres
fins et que donc ça nous aide évidemment
à permettre à l'Arménie de protéger des
vies et d'assurer aussi la sécurité de
son territoire évidemment ça va dans le
bon sens mais je pourrais y revenir
peut-être aussi annoncer au Sénat que
j'aurai de nouveau un contact avec le
ministre de la Défense Arménie la
semaine prochaine qui nous permettra
justement de finaliser un certain nombre
de de choses sur le terrain très
opérationnel et concrets voilà pour dire
les choses mais enfin vous le voyez bien
on on est engagé en tout cas moi je je
le suis à titre personnel et et je suis
particulièrement touché par par ce qui
se passe et je pense que c'est l'intérêt
de la France j'en suis persuadé que de
que de montrer cet exemple sur les mgcs
euh écoutez le dossier avance bien
euh je pense aussi que nous avons appris
du SCAF
euh nous sommes chef de fil sur le SCAF
dasso est donc leader sur le SCAF les
Allemands sont chefs de fil sur le mgcs
pour autant on voit bien aussi dans la
phase 1 B du SCAF qui fonctionne bien en
terme de méthode euh et on voit VO bien
aussi ce qui n'a pas bien fonctionné au
début du SCAF et donc le fait que les
deux armées de terre s'accordent sur un
besoin opérationnel avec la signature de
ce document Évreux va dans le bon sens
ça permet aussi quand même d'éviter un
certain nombre de scénarios dans
lequel on peut aller dans un sens de
direction de ce que sera le futur char
je rappelle quand même qu'on parle d'un
char à horison 2040 et suivant 2040 2050
2060 enfin je veux dire parfois dans la
presse allemande ou française on a
l'impression qu'on parle su P et simple
du du Leclerc ou du successeur pur et
simple du léopard je veux dire bon la
discussion d' vreux pu j verni à
domicile
elle a permis au moins avec les deux
armées de terre et les deux ministres et
les deux équipes diplomatiques de de
s'accorder aussi sur le le niveau de jeu
que doit être ce
char habité non habité quel est la
plateforme de drone
autour quelle est la part de feu de
nouvelle génération et j'entends dans
votre question euh quelques quelques
inquiétudes que je peux entendre ici ou
là chez Nexter enfin je les aime
par-dessus tout Nexter c'est pour ça que
sur l'économie de guerre je ne les ai
pas lâché qu'aujourd'hui ils ont quand
même les satisfaits sites de l'armée
ukrainienne devant la terre entière et
que la terre entière veut acheter du
César c'est aussi parce que j'ai ce
niveau d'exigence avec cette entreprise
que j'aime profondément dont on a besoin
de se savoir faire là mais de considérer
que le feu classique sera le seul feu
entre 2040 et 2070 ça serait suici
suicidaire on a déjà raté l'étape des
drones on va pas continuer je pense donc
je le dis aussi avec beaucoup de
d'affection à l'industrie en question ne
pas se poser la question ou ou banaliser
en disant ou oui arme à énergie dirigé
canon laser tout ça c'est c'est c'est
c'est pour rire parce que le vrai sujet
c'est le feu classique vous voyez ce que
je veux dire je pense qu'on fait fausse
route je vous dis comme je le pense
c'est un Paris technologique on peut ne
pas être d'accord et ce une fois que
j'ai dit ça il y a pas de schéma dans le
lequel on prendra des décisions qui
seront contraire à un externe voilà pour
dire les choses très très directement
mais on n'est pas là que pour aussi
s'occuper des intérêts du moment d'une
entreprise et même si j'en suis le
ministre de tutelle et vous connaissez
mon engagement sur cette affaire je je
ferai ce qu'il faut on est là aussi pour
s'assurer que l'armée de terre est le
bon char en
2050 que que nous ne soyons pas 2040 que
nous ne soyons pas la génération de
décideurs
politiques qui qui avont fait le
contresens total des choix techno qu'il
fallait faire des briques techno il
fallait faire pour ce char je pense que
c'est ça le niveau de jeu et l'équipe du
ministre pisterius pour le coup est
là-dessus ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
avec un ministre francophone francophile
je je tiens vraiment à le dire parce que
il il y met beaucoup du sien pour que
tout cela avance dans le bon sens après
sur la répartition des rôles
SCAF puisque ce sont les conditions que
les Allemands on demandaient à la France
il y a aucune raison qu'on fasse pas la
même chose pour le char 50 il y a un
chef de fil faut le respecter ce sont
les Allemands on va pas non plus retirer
aux Allemands leur savoir-faire en
matière de production ce genre
d'équipement terrestre c'est une réalité
donc on a aussi quelque chose à
bénéficier ne soyons pas que chauin non
plus sinon sans quoi on s'abîme dans la
discussion accessoirement 5050 comme
pour le SCAF accessoirement des piliers
qui ne sont pas qu'une méthode c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment faut aussi
répartir tout ça de manière un peu
sérieuse avec derrière des fonctions
dans chaque pilier qui permet aussi de
bâtir le 5050 au sein de chacun des
piliers et ça pour le coup c'est notre
intérêt mais je n'ai pas de doute et
c'est aussi l'intérêt des Allemands la
prochaine étape sera la suivante
commencer à mettre des drapeaux sur les
morceaux de piliers voilà c'est ce qui
nous attend c'est devant nous pour
l'instant les choses avancent bien
euh je sais que c'est un projet qui
suscite beaucoup de doutes euh vous
savez vous connaissez mongolisme par
ailleurs donc je ne suis pas européen ba
mais enfin des grands projets menés de
des grands projets concrets menés de gré
à gré avec des états volontaires c'est
un peu l'aventure Arian jadis c'est
aussi ce qu'on peut réussir à faire
surtout sur un segment sur lequel je
vous le rappelle mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs nous n'aurons jamais de000
chars notre modèle d'armée nous emmènera
jamais à avoir une cible de char
gigantesque parce que tout ce que vous
connaissez déjà puissance dotée capacité
expéditionnaire qui est évidemment
caréné pour des objets très concrets
donc voilà je rendrai compte au Sénat
régulièrement peut-être aussi parfois
j'avance monsieur le Président euh
peut-être aussi parfois hclos pour
peut-être aussi ne pas ne pas donner
trop d'indications publiques sur ces
sujets mais en tout cas le le dossier
avance bien euh sur les autres points
madame conoué Mouret sur Kief
partenariat alors les sessions vont
continuer mais je l'ai indiqué parce que
la presse a vite dit ça y est il y a
plus de session maintenant on va vendre
des armes non les sessions continuent en
revanche sur certains types d'équip
d'équipement ça devra devenir
l'exception tout simplement parce qu'on
ne pourra pas prélever d'avantage dans
le stock des armées françaises et que
pardon mais on le voit bien cette guerre
va durer et donc par définition notre
fiabilité va reposer sur notre
indendurance et pourquoi nous avions
parlé d'économie de guerre B nous y
sommes c'est qu'à un moment donné nos
industries de défense doit pouvoir
fournir un pays en guerre en espérant
que ça ne soit pas le nôtre mais en tout
cas l'Ukraine est un pays amis en guerre
qui a besoin d'un certain nombre
d'équipement 18 entreprises étaient avec
moi pour ce salon de l'armement nous
étions d'ailleurs la délégation
occidentale enfin la délégation tout
court la plus importante donc je tiens
remercier quand même les les membres de
la BITD PME PMI comme les grandes
entreprises euh qui peuvent conduire des
partenariats très concrets on en a déjà
l'habitude parce que dans nos dans notre
culture à l'export on a déjà l'habitude
de mener ce genre de chos interroge
naval group tous les bateaux sont pas
toujours produits sur le territoire
national vous avez des des des des
accords qui se font avec des chantiers
navals pareil pour la production
terrestre aujourd'hui une partie du MCO
du César est faite par des entreprises
qui avant la guerre faisaient de
l'entretien de matériel agroalimentaire
bon mais le principe d'une industrie de
défense c'est aussi de travailler pour
des pays qui sont en
guerre oui mais je le dis enfin notre
industrie de défense doit travailler
pour des pays qui sont en guerre je je
je le dis alors après à la question le
risque pour les salariés moi les choses
sont claires de ce qui me remonte au
moment où je vous parle ce sonont
essentiellement des salariés ukrainiens
et s'il y a des salariés français
forcément sur la base du volontariat et
c'est aux entreprises évidemment de
prendre leur responsabilité voilà tout
simplement et nous on les accompagnera
pour le faire mais il y a aucune
dimension dans lequelle on forcera qui
que ce soit à le faire et globalement
mais les chefs d'entreprise la BTD que
vous auditionnerez monsieur le Président
vous le diront il y a plutôt du
volontariat de la motivation pour le
faire le sénateur Ludovic était avec moi
sur la mission à Kief pour en témoigner
la discuter longuement avec les les
différents entrepreneurs B voilà mais le
le principe dominant ce sont des
salariés Ukrainiens ce sont des des
filiales potentiel des sous-traitances
des John ventur voilà des outils qui
nous permettront de le de le faire Arac
euh bon c'est un projet très intéressant
pour être très clair
pardon c'est un projet très intéressant
pour être très clair euh ça va beaucoup
dépendre du premier vol qui va être
attendu évidemment dans dans les tous
prochains mois et globalement le travail
est de bonne qualité en confiance avec
turjis et Gaillard avec les différents
services du du ministère là vous savez
qu'il y a un patch drone dans le dans la
LPM qui va nous permettre justement
d'explorer un certain nombre de de de
concepts en tout cas c'est la DGA qui
suit la faire avec les armées mais c'est
un projet qui est bien suivi et quand je
parlais de programmation vivante bah
voilà aussi des enjeux techn qui
peutvent évidemment s'inviter dans la
programmation très bien un beau
programme une belle innovation à rooc
euh par une entreprise française si vous
permettez donc programme suivant
programme 178 préparation lo d'effce
Olivier sigolotti puis Michel Grot mais
je vous appelle à la synthèse parce que
parce que j'ai cinq demandes de parole
après merci oui monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur le Ministre une fois
n'est pas coutume je ne vous
interrogerai pas ni sur la DT la DTO l'
MCO ou le PM ne vous étonnerez pas mais
je je souhaitais revenir sur le Niger
vous avez effleuré dans votre propos
liminire deux deux sujets qui à mon sens
sont une importance vitale en quittant
le nigère nous nous allons abandonner
l'un de nos dernier point d'appui
stratégique nous allons passer d'une
vingtaine de de base une vingtaine
comise que nous avions au Mali au
Burkina Faso et au Niger au début de
l'année prochaine a pratiquement aucune
quelle stratégie comptez-vous mettre en
œuvre pour palier notre départ forcé du
du Sahel et comment évaluez-vous les
conséquences budgétaires de de
l'évolution de de nos forces
prépositionné voilà monsieur le
Président une question une double
question
syth merci Michel Grum bon merci
Monsieur le Ministre tout à l'heure pour
les éléments donnés sur le service de
santé du de de l'armée on sait très bien
qu'il est en difficulté comme l'ont
montré les travaux du Sénat avec un
récent rapport de la Cour des comptes
après des années de diminution des
crédits et des personnels plusieurs
enjeux sont critiques comme la nécessité
d'une montée en puissance révélée par la
guerre en Ukraine mais pas que une
meilleure articulation avec les hôpitaux
civils le renforcement des hôpitaux
militaires des mesures fortes pour
averser la dégradation de l'attractivité
et surtout de la fidélisation mais cela
ne suffira pas à rendre le SSA capable
de faire face à la haute intensité en
effet celle-ci implique potentiellement
un afflux de blessés qui ne pourrait
être pris en compte qu'à travers une
coordination parfaite avec le système
hospitalier civil lui-même exang il faut
donc une nouvelle organisation
d'ensemble du parcours du militaire
blessé avec les moyens correspondants
monsieur le ministre quel effort seront
réalisé en 2024 pour atteindre cet
objectif euh ma seconde question se
porte sur les les Jeux Olympiques samedi
dernier un article de la presse
régionale valmtin a fait état d'un
recours possible à 18000 militaires pour
sécuriser les j sous la forme d'une
force déployée pour une durée de 4 mois
et qui porterait le nom
d'oplit est-ce que cette information est
exacte naturellement si c'était le cas
ce serait d'une portée considérraable
pour nos armées et nous souhaiterions
alors avoir des précisions sur
l'organisation la logistique les moyens
matériels et financiers qui seront
mobilisé pour faire face à cette
nouvelle mission
mercis ministre à vous la parole je
faire des réponses beaucoup plus bref
monsieur le questeur sigetti sur le
Niger bon conséquence budgétaire déjà le
redéploiement logistique en tant que tel
va en avoir pas de doute si on prend
globalement ce qui s'est passé pour le
Mali c'est un peu tôt pour être
complètement définitif sur un chiffrage
enfin on pourrait être entre 200 et 400
millions
d'euros quand on dit ça en général on
est souvent plus près des 400 des 200
donc pour la logistique en tant que tel
je l'indiqué tout à l'heure aussi pour
la la la remise en conditions
opérationnelles des matériels qui est un
point évidemment absolument important
alors
après la question est intéressante c'est
comment palier mais en fait la base
aérienne projetée que nous avions à
Niamé elle n'avait qu'une seule fonction
stratégique lutter contre le terrorisme
au côté des Nigériens pas pas de
Communauté française très importante au
nigerre elle a été évacuée par
ailleurs donc en fait vous voyez il y a
souvent aussi je je MTA employé à cet
exercice devant vous lors du débat
effectivement qui avait été demandé par
le le groupe socialiste sur sur
l'Afrique c'est que au fond il y a à
chaque base correspond des fonctions
militaires très différentes Sénégal et
au Gabon contrairement à ce qui a pu
être raconé ici là dans la presse il n'y
a aucune fonction de combat ce n'est que
de l'offre de formation quand je dis
aucune fonction de combat il faut
visiter le camp de Gaulle euh à Dakar
pour pour comment dire à à Libreville
euh où également évidemment le le les
forces françaises qui sont au au revoir
monsieur le Président qui sont au au
Sénégal pour voir en fait que on on est
uniquement sur une offre de formation
inversement
euh au Niger où on était sur une
formation très opérationnelle et et sur
de la pu au combat bon mais comme
d'ailleurs on fait de l'appuie au combat
d'ailleurs je m'en veux de l'avoir
oublié monsieur le Président niau mois
nous nous l'avons fait mais depuis que
nous nous sommes quittés nous avons
aussi perdu trois soldats en Irak parce
que la lutte contre le terrorisme elle
n'est pas terminée et compris au levant
sur lequel on est discret par définition
enfin il y a une activité opérationnelle
des forces pour des raisons que l'on
sait donc en fait en fonction des bases
vous avez des intérêts différents le
sénateur Alizard a posé la question de
Djibouti là vous avez une base qui est
tournée à la fois vers le pays haute
parce qu' il y a un accord de défense
avec une clause de sécurité mais qui au
fond quand même une base qui est
davantage tournée vers l'Indo-Pacifique
qu' est tourné véritablement vers le
continent africain donc en fait le Niger
était une base qui per qui était au
service du des Nigériens dès lors que
les Nigériens ne combatre plus le
terrorisme euh mais on les on les
rapatrie non mais plus drone mais on va
pas combattre terroriste à la place de
de d'armée qui ne souhaitf en tout cas
de de jeintes qui ne souhait plus le
faire je pense que c'est le moment de
vérité et c'est c'est en cela que c'est
c'est pas un échec de la diplomatie
française c'est un échec terrible pour
les populations nigériennes ou Mali
ou Burkinabes d'ailleurs donc il y a des
moyens il y avait de l'engagement et
au-delà des moyens des soldats qui sont
tombés là il y avait une volonté
politique de lutter contre le terrorisme
avec une mise en œuvre opérationnelle
sur le terrain il y en a plus nous n'y
sommes plus je ne sais pas ce que demain
sera fait en tout cas je pense que c'est
un point évidemment important madame la
signatrice Grum service de santé des
armées 70 millions d'euros de plus pour
l'année prochaine c'est 30 % de de de 33
% de plus avec que je vous l'ai dit des
des urgences importantes sur les grands
hôpitaux sur les antennes chirurgicales
sur les ambulances et un point
d'attention particulier sur les
réservistes puisque c'est un des moyens
enfin fidélisation des militaires
d'actifs du SSA et de le et des
personnels civils mais aussi évidemment
recrutement dans la réserve puisquun des
moyens aussi de faire face à la haute
intensité éventuelle et la
multiplication de crise c'est évidemment
d'avoir une réserve du SSA qui se durcit
amplement plus évidemment les stratégies
différents hôpitaux en région qui
doivent recoller aussi à la vie des
forces euh y compris sur les blessures
psychiques y compris sur les soins à
apporter au aux combattants euh et donc
là aussi des des expérimentations
intéressantes vont avoir lieu entre un
certain nombre de de Pitau du SSA en
région avec l'instittu des Invalides
parce qu'on le voit bien en plus d'Atos
on a besoin d'occuper un autre segment
sur la blessure du combattant y compris
de la blessure psychique et puis
évidemment le nouveau projet euh à
Marseille euh la ministre Carlotti est
juste derrière vous euh sur un un un
projet très important immobilier mais
pas que d'aménagement du territoire mais
pas que de contact aux force mais pas
que qui va être aussi quand même l'outil
l'infrastructure hospitalière militaire
de de de Marseille va dire quelque chose
aussi du SSA demain et donc ça sera
aussi un dossier sur lequel j'aurai
l'occasion de revenir voilà pour être un
peu plus synthétique
pardonnez-moi merci monsieur le ministre
et pour terminer euh sur le p212 soutien
de la politique de défense Joël guerot
puis mariearlette
Carlotti monsieur le ministre concernant
les recrutements vous avez donc affiché
une création net de
456 militaires euh ma question porte
alors que nous avions sur la LPM un
objectif de 700 ma question porte donc
j'aurais donc trois questions
la
première c'est comment vous êtes arrivé
à établir ce chiffre de 456 ma seconde
question est-ce qu'il y a un risque de
sous-utilisation c'estàd de ne pas
atteindre ce chiffre et troisièmement
comment dans ce ces difficultés
recrutement auquel vous avez pu être
confronté allez-vous procéder de façon à
créer de plus d'attractivité sur les
métiers
militaires excellent Joë très
synthétique Marie Arlette merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre vous
le savez les difficultés de recrutement
dont vient de parler mon collègue et de
fidélisation des militaires inquièteent
les état-majors nous inquiète nous aussi
nous l'avions d'ailleurs évoqué lordre
la loi de programmation militaire elle
nous inquiète d'autant plus que le
contexte géostratégique est étendu donc
moi je vais me concentrer sur la
question de la fidélisation vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure la nouvelle
politique de rémunération c'est bien
mais contrairement à ce que son nom
indique ça ne concerne que les primes et
le tassement des grilles les unes par
rapport aux autres et par rapport au
cadre de la fonction publique inquiète
énormément les officiers qui sentent que
pour eux il y a un déclassement alors
pouvez-vous nous apporter des précisions
sur le calendrier effectivement retenu
pour la révision des grilles indiciaires
et sa mise en œuvre parce que la loi de
programmation militaire ne prévoit
qu'une date butoire et pas de calendrier
euh et et du coup vous avez vu que le
Haut comité d'évaluation de la condition
militaire souhaite que une fois que tout
ça sera mis en place place on commence
avant tout par les les officiers pour
leur donner au plus vite un espèce de
sens de de l'escalier social que
pensez-vous de ça tout à l'heure vous
avez évoqué le plan famille merci il
avance plutôt bien mais vous savez aussi
que les questions de logement sont des
préoccupations importantes pour les
militaires et le plan ambition logement
qui a été signé en début 2022 prévoit la
rénovation complète du parc et prévoit
aussi la construction de près de 2800
logements d'ici 2030 là encore les
documents budgétaires sont discrets sur
sa mise en œuvre est-ce que vous pouvez
me dire comment ce plan va
avancer merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
beaucoup monsieur sénateur guerot là
aussi je vais être plus plus rapide et
et synthétique sur les
456 ETP c'est tout simplement la
l'addition des besoins exprimés par
service donc vous êtes sur une
construction très très fine avec les
objectifs et les priorités que j'ai
définis je vous ai cité tout à l'heure
on voit bien je dire les services de
renseignement occupent une bonne part et
puis les soutiens peut pas parler de
cohérence et de masse puis un moment
donné ne pas aussi faire ce qu'il faut
sur le SCA le SSA voilà donc en fait ce
sont les besoins concrets exprimés par
les différents grands chefs des
directions priuritaire à mes yeux du du
ministère qui ont permis de le faire
sachant que ça ne veut pas dire que dans
d'autres univers du ministère vous allez
pas avoir des gros mouvements de TP vous
aurez l'occasion évidemment d'interroger
pierre chill le général d'armée pierre
chill le c'est mat sur le pivot au sein
de l'armée de Terre puisqueaprès vous
avez des redéploiements de TP donc là on
est vraiment sur la création de TP hors
redéploiement pour évidemment répondre à
la question des 456 attractivité des
métiers militaires maintenant c'est de
l'art d'exécution euh enfin il y a tout
ce qui est exogène he le marché de
l'emploi et cetera ça a des conséquences
majeures sur un grand ministère
employeur évidemment comme comme celui
que j'ai l'onneur de diriger euh après
vous avez beaucoup de choses qui sont
votées décidé dans la loi de
programmation militaire et qui vont
évidemment produire leurs effets je je
pense qu'il faut qu'on parle de plus en
plus de métier puisqueau fond
d'attractivité comme ça globale je veux
dire il y a toujours enfin on en parle
jamais mais il y a commême 60000 civils
le ministère des armées c'est qu'il y a
plus de civils le ministère des armées
qu'il n en a la plupart des autres
ministères de la République et dans les
interpellations diverses et variées les
militaires occupent évidemment une bonne
partie c'est bien naturel c'est pas moi
qui ve dire le contraire j'aiussi passé
beaucoup de temps avec les syndicats du
du ministère des armées là aussi il y a
évidemment des enjeux en d'attractivité
donc après il y a des au-delà de ce qui
est écrit dans la programmation
militaire sur l'indicire l'indemnitaire
le plan famille tout ça je vais revenir
dans un instant pour la min Carti mais
il y a évidemment aussi les parcours les
débouchés
les vous êtes civil au ministère des
armées bah c'est sûr que la perspective
de de d'avoir une visibilité sur une
carrière complète et est plus complexe
euh que sur d'autres ministères parce
que très vite vous avez des voies de
débouché qui sont bah qui sont
précisément bouché donc ça c'est
évidemment des des des points importants
il y a un sujet qui est tonique euh en
terme euh d'ambiance au sein du
ministère entre les civiles et les
militaires c'est euh quel quels sont les
postes qui ont vocation à être toujours
dévolués à des civils ou d'autres à des
militaires ça euh j'en parle avec
précaution euh en me en en me mettant
tout de suite en sécurité euh mais mais
je sais que ce sont quand même des
sujets sur quel il faudra évidemment
qu'on les traite parce que parce que
voilà et puis après vous avez des
dynamiques géographiques moi je suis
quand même frappé de voir que quand on
garde les grands agrégats ça je vous
inviterai pourraz vous les communiquer
monsieur le Président bah au fond on
voit bien quand même que la fameuse
attrition ou les problèmes de
fidélisation sont pas complètement
égales sur le territoire
national c'est une évidence et et la
métropolisation de tout ce que ça peut
vouloir dire a des effets que il y a des
dynamiques dans le grandesses qui sont
pas celles qu'on retrouve dans d'autres
régions enfin tout ça pardon est une
évidence mais je peux quand même le
redire c'est qu'en fait on a des outils
qui sont globaux pour des problèmes de
dynamiques qui sont très régionales et
je suis sûr que si vous interrogez le
ministre de la Justice ou le ministre de
l'Intérieur il vous direz que pour ces
tribunaux ou euh ces préfectures il a
parfois aussi les mêmes difficultés en
tout cas moi je vois pour ce que je
connais le mieux la basarenne d'vreux
euh les difficultés que l'on peut avoir
la basarenne d'evreuse sont celles que
le Conseil départemental de l'UR au
hasard pour prendre une collectivité que
je connais bien peut avoir donc après il
y a des dynamique vous voyez que je vais
essayer aussi de traiter
territorialement et pas que
nationalement sans quoi on videra la mer
avec une petite cuillère
euh alors calendrier plan famille hccm
alors il y a un calendrier dans la loi
que des parlementaires avait amendé euh
qui prévoit militaire Durang dès cette
année sans attendre la la LPM enfin
l'année 2024 priorité au sous-officiers
en 2024 et officiers en 2025 alors
attention quand on dit ça ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a rien pour les officiers
d'ici en 2025 parce que vous avez toute
la part indemnitaire qui va tomber avec
la
nprm ce que le rapport du HCM traite
c'est
l'indicière c'est très bien mais quand
d'ailleurs ils font ces comparaisons
avec les administrateurs généraux de
l'État ou les administrateurs de l'État
par ailleurs il ne compare que de
l'indicière et de l'indicière là ou dans
la Solle de l'officier comme vous le
savez il y a une énorme part
indemnitaire mais qui est le le le
reflet même du statut militaire alors
pour être h quand j'ai été nommé j'ai
reçu tous les grands chefs militaires
avant un CSFM et je leur ai dit c'était
le moment où je pouvais encore ou pas
appuyer sur le dernier la troisème
tranche de la nprm celle qui tombe là
c'est il y a un an et demi j'avais dit
grand chef militaire au Semma au SEM au
drhmd au secrétaire général pour
l'administration je leur avais dit mais
au fond quand même y a une bonne part
d'indemnitaire et une part d'indiciaire
que c'est le bon chemin tout le monde
l'avait défendu la société militaire
avait défendu cet équilibre entre
l'indemnitaire et l'indiciaire quand
vous réinjectez l'indemnitaire vous avez
pour le coup en pouvoir d'achat réel sur
certains sur les déciles quand on
regarde par décil vous avez pour le coup
un des soldes qui sont plus importantes
que certains administrateurs de l'État
donc ça si vous le souhaitez on pourra
l'objectiver moi j'ai reçu évidemment
l'équipe du du du ha comité j'ai j'ai
accusé réception un certain nombre de
leurs recommandations sont satisfaites
dans la LPM d'autres vont faire l'objet
d'un travail complémentaire je pense que
le rapport a quand même aussi traité le
la question des officiers de
Ballard tout n'est pas qu'à faire de
l'argent c'est aussi à faire de de vie
quotidienne donc là je vais signer un
mandat aussi sur ces sujets parce que je
pense que c'est intéressant de
travailler sereinement sur cette affaire
et sur les chiffres qui sont indiqués
dans le dans le rapport qui est un
rapport bien fait on va aussi le le le
documenter le nourrir aussi pour la
suite parce que évidemment si on fait
que de l'indiciare alors qu'on a un
énorme chantier indemnitaire en même
temps c'est évidemment le problème en
tout cas je pourrais revenir plan
famille les choses avancent logement
vous avez raison je pense qu'on est pas
au bout de tous les toutes les solutions
je vous l'avais déjà dit plusieurs fois
ministère des armé est parfois très très
jacobin euh donc la volonté de régler le
sujet du logement que par nous-mêm or
moi je reste persuadé qu'il y a des
solutions qui peuvent être trouvées avec
les collectivités territoriales avec la
Caisse des dépôts de plus en plus un
sujet monte que le sujet de la de la
caution pour les loyers des ayants droit
de nos militaires vous êtes sergent vous
devez loger votre enfant étudiant à
Paris euh la nature même de votre
contrat fait que pour un propriétaire
loin la appartement c'est pas toujours
ça est-ce qu'on peut pas trouver des
solutions de substitution de garantie
c'est autant de sujet sur lequel je suis
en train de faire travailler mes équipes
parce que je vois bien qu'il faut qu'on
soit capable de faire du sur mesure il y
a aussi la question de l'accès aux soins
on viient aussi sur le SSA parce que je
pense qu'il faut un gros module
sanitaire dans le plan famille pardon je
redeviens
long merci merci Monsieur le Ministre on
passe aux questions une minute je
rappelle qu'on a décidé ce matin que on
allait chronométrer pour essayer le plus
possible d'être dans les temps donc je
je proposerai je proposerai à à Chac
quel de s'exprimer et puis après je vous
répondrai globalement le premier avoir
demandé la parole c'est Michel Valet qui
est je rappelle rapporteur pour avis au
p29
également merci monsieur le Président
bonjour monsieur le ministre avant de
poser ma question votre ministère est
très jacobin c'est pas une insulte hein
c'est pas interdit non plus bien surtout
de la part d'un ministère
égalien ma question porte sur la
question cyber et ça ne porte pas sur la
question du montant parce que je pense
qu'on est globalement satisfait de ce
qu'il y a dans la LPM et c'est là des
raisons pour lesquelles on a on a
soutenu mais sur la façon d'exécuter la
LPM et sur la politique de gestion
humaine de de la ressource c'est aussi
comme ça a été évoqué sur d'autres
métiers une question d'attractivité l'
LPM prévoit 900 emplois supplémentaires
sur un total d'environ euh 500 5500
postes à l'horizon 2030 et nous avons
estimé que 1100 postes de cyber
combattant n'étaient déjà à ce jour pas
pourvu j'ajoute à ça que dans les
différents déplacements que nous faisons
avec avec mon collègue Olivier cadi on
est allé avant l'été notamment à la DGA
et au com cyber à Rennes ce qu'on entend
c'est qu'il y a une espèce de
concurrence un peu malsine mais c'est un
état de fitete entre des structures qui
sont publiques ou parapuiques tout le
monde s'arrache les ingénieurs ou les
sachants dans ce domainelà il y a une
concurrence entre entre organismes qui
relèvent pourtant de de l'État on a donc
un besoin exponentiel et ma question
c'est est-ce que vous avez une idée de
la façon dont vous allez gérer
l'attractivité sur ces métiers là il y a
des des pays à l'étranger y compris des
grandes démocraties qui repèent les
ingénieurs quasiment au collège comme on
repère des joueurs de foot alors on n
est peut-être pas là en France mais
quelle est votre opinion sur le sujet et
surtout votre façon d'aborder les choses
je vous remercie merci Michel la deuxème
question André
guol merci président monsieur le
ministre notre commission a souhaité la
création d'un pôle de compétences dans
le domaine des grands fonds sous-marins
et la fait inscrire dans le rapport
annexé de la loi de programmation
militaire
2024-230 il n'est pas besoin ici de
rappeler l'importance de disposer d'une
bonne maîtrise des grands fonds
océaniques en créant ce pôle de compéten
qui touche les domaines du milieu
d'évolution de nos sous-marins et
intègre donc entre autres notre
dissuasion nucléaire mais aussi le
milieu des drones et des robots
sous-marins la protection des
câblismergés de communication et de
transport d'énergie ainsi que des
pipelines les richesses aliotiques et
minérales qu'il convient d'exploiter
avec prudence sans oublier la
connaissance scientifique de la
biodiversité restant à découvrir et à
protéger même si beaucoup de choses
existent déjà l'approche transverse et
duale du futur pôle de compétenence une
fois
structureux structuré permettrait une
meilleure synergie nationale et de se
réapproprier une compétence que
l'arsenal de toulom possédait jadis avec
la construction notamment de baptiscaf
et du sous-marin notile capable de
plonger à 6000 m désormais monsieur le
ministre fort de cette nouvelle LPM que
vous avez porté comment comptez-vous
traduire budgetirement dans le prochain
dans le prochain PLF 2024 cette volonté
de voir émerger et surtout de mettre en
action ce nouveau pôle de compéten dont
la France souhaiterait se doter je vous
remercie merci André Philippe
folot merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous vous avez dit
au début de votre propos que l'objectif
de cette loi de programmation militaire
c'était de se préparer pour la guerre du
futur la guerre de futur elle est sous
nos yeux elle est en Europe elle est en
Ukraine
et vous êtes allé sur place j'ai aussi
le l'opportunité au mois de janvier
comme au mois de juillet de me rendre
sur place et d'aller deux fois sur la
ligne de front et qu'est-ce que j'ai pu
constater c'est que cette guerre est une
guerre duale c'est une guerre
technologique du 21e siècle mais c'est
aussi une guerre de tranchée c'est à
certains égards une guerre de position
du début du du 20e siècle avec tout ce
que cela comporte c'estàdire que le
facteur humain quoi qu'il quoi que l'on
en pense restera toujours un élément
essentiel et du restes au regard de ce
qui s'est passé à Gaza on a vu peut-être
des limites du du tout technologique en
terme de protection à à certains égards
mais ce que ce qui me paraît important
et essentiel c'est que vous avez vous y
êtes allé avec une délégation
industrielle par rapport à des objectifs
qui seront des objectifs de coopération
à moyen et et à long terme dans les
effets mais les besoins ils sont
immédiats moi j'ai pu constater sur le
terrain et vous l'avez souligné monsieur
le ministre toute la pertinence et toute
l'importance j'allais tactique et
stratégique du canon César j'ai pu aussi
constater que peut-être nos AMX 10 RC
avaiit peut-être un petit peu moins de
un petit peu moins d'utilité mais par
rapport à tout cela que faire pour
accélérer nos livraisons d'armement
lesquels combien et
quand merci Philippe Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine merci président monsieur le
ministre deux questions une question au
système d'homme une question au système
d'art euh s'agissant des des hommes euh
il y a le plan 2uxème volet du plan
famille euh 750 millions d'euros un
changement de culture aussi avec
beaucoup plus vous le disiez de de de de
pouvoir au niveau local peut-être aussi
un meilleur travail avec les
collectivités locales peut-être si vous
pouviez revenir et détailler ce plan
au-delà des des 750 millions d'euros un
petit point d'attention sur l'IGESA
beaucoup de militaires veulent acheter
euh et la capacité de trait d'absorption
manifestement nécessite d'être d'être
adapté deuxième question sur les
innovations vous y êtes revenu assez
longuement je veux appeler votre
attention naturellement sur l'intérêt du
quantique et vous le savez par rapport à
l'augmentation de la performance que
cela permet c'est vrai dans le nucléaire
lorsque justement l'ordinateur quantique
succédera au super calculateur c'est
vrai dans d'autres domaines donc c'est
c'est une chance et une nécessité
ardente pour rester leader et donc après
le plan quantique lancé par le président
dans le cadre de France 2030 mais qui va
jusqu'à 2025 il y a aussi besoin de
réfléchir peut-être à à une deuxème
phase et à ses applications dans le
domaine militaire là aussi je suis
preneur de de votre avis sur comment
tirer le meilleure parti du quantique
pour nos armées merci Jean-Baptiste
Patrice
jolie merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre après des questions
et des réponsse très technique très
pointue une question un peu générale qui
tient au fait que j'arrive dans cette
commission et avec des choses qui sont
très nouvelles pour moi question
d'élément de comparaison regarde
l'évolution du contexte géopolitique
nous avez évoqué que cette année donc il
s'agissait d'un budget qui déclinait la
loi de programmation militaire depuis le
vote de cette loi les évolutions
géopolitiques continuent à à à évoluer
et et de manière parfois dramatique
d'ailleurs et je voudais savoir si on
compare les budgets qui en tout cas les
les prévisions de budget pour la Chine
pour pour les États-Unis pour les pays
de l'Union européenne c'està-dire en
fait pour les pays qui disposent de
moyens militaires savoir si les
orientations que de de ces pays évoluent
et si nous sommes dans le bon tempo en
quelque sorte en terme de volume
financier d la défense et au regarde des
orientations des objectifs et des
secteurs priorisés qui peuvent être
poursuivis merci et pour terminer Robert
rovier merci président monsieur le
ministre le Bassac septembre dernier
l'Observatoire des armements a mis en
ligne son dernier rapport qui montre que
la France a continué à exporter des bi
double usage à la Russie en 2022 en
clair l'Observatoire affirme que des
composants électroniques pouvant avoir
un usage civil ou militaire ont continué
à être exportés vers Moscou et ce bien
après l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014
notutre document est cette fois-ci
recueilli par le journal d'investigation
blast conforte cette appression cette
fois en 2023 selon les documents de
douanes russes le livraison de matériel
mine France aurit continué bien après le
début des combats au moins jusqu'au en
avril 2023 malgré les sanctions
française européennes américaines et
l'embargo international sous le soutien
d'ffectif de la force à l'effort de
guerre ukrainien mon groupe demande des
documents précis permettant de vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas à l'heure actuelle
d'exportation de B à double usage à des
pays qui commettent aujourd'hui des
crimes de guerre seriez-vous disposé
monsieur le ministre à les transmettre à
la représentation nationale merci
merci et pour terminer j'avais pas si
j'ais demandé la parole pardon je
pensais avoir été vu mais çaatt bien que
soit le dernier pass une question
uniquement girande par rapport au
ministère alors alors puque tu l' prends
vas-y parler vous en parlerez peut-être
commission pour terminer donc
complètement Ludovic merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre mes chers
collègues je vais faire très vite 450
milliards de dollars c'est le poids du
marché spatial en 2023 un marché qui
devrait doubler d'ici 2030 les chiffres
sont astronomiques et ils m'amènent à
aborder aujourd'hui avec vous le sujet
essentiel de la défense française et
européenne en une décennie la croissance
vertigineuse de l'industrie spatiale
fait de ce domaine secteur les plus
attractifs du du du niveau spatial et
les innovations les usages ils sont
multiplié je pense notamment à
l'émergence des lanceurs réutilisables
afin de réduire le coût d'accès à
l'espace les constellations de
satellites offrant une connectivité
rapide et plus étendue que la fibre ou
encore à l'exploitation des ressources
spatiales des missions de surveillance
et d'observation de la Terre alors si
les États-Unis et la Chine ont été
précurseurs sur ce marché l'Union
européenne n'est pas en reste en portant
plusieurs projets essentiels celui de la
stratégie spatiale de l'UE pour la
sécurité l'établissement d'un code de la
route pour la circulation des objets
dans l'espace aussi appelé gestion du
trafic spatial et ainsi que la
fourniture de lanceurs nouvelle
génération comme Arian 6 et et Vega à
ceci s'ajoute la mobilisation des
acteurs incontournables de l'industrie
spatiale européenne qui ont annoncé
vouloir joindre leurs forces pour la
conception de la future constellation de
satellite de communication iris alors
Monsieur le Ministre votre action et
celle de votre ministère ont permis
d'injecter 6 milliards d'euros de la LPM
2024-2030 au renforcement de l'action de
la France dans l'espace comment
envisagez-vous monsieur le ministre la
cohabitation des projets de défense avec
la stratégie civile déjà mise en place
merci Monsieur le Ministre on rend
l'antenne à cognacg à 18h15 donc je vous
laisse terminer donc discipliner pour
faire des des réponses plus brèves enfin
je prends aussi ces questions comme une
invitation à à consacrer peut-être
d'autres séances sur les thématiques ça
permet aussi d'avoir quelque chose de
plus fouillé enfin moi je suis
évidemment disponible monsieur le
sénateur valet alors sur le cyber je
pense qu'en fait on a deux combat en
même temps le combat de de de la lutte
contre
l'atrition contre
l'anthropophagie fagie pardon
interministériel ou même
internominarme pour le coup beaucoup a
été fait entre DGA et D GSE sous couvert
du secrétarat général pour
l'administration il y a une coordination
qui qui se fait jour il trve que j'ai
recruté comme directeur de cabinet
Patrick paayou qui a été le premier
patron préfigurateur et créateur de
l'ancy et directeur technique de la DGSE
pendant pratiquement plus de 8 temps
c'est un choix aussi délibéré que j'ai
fait pour aussi rentrer dans cette dans
cette sphère là donc évidemment il y a
ce il y a ce combat là le deuxième
combat en fait c'est tout simplement le
vivier initial euh bon moi je suis
frappé quand même de voir que le que le
le ce qu'on a demandé sur le BTS cyber
là qui va doubler ses effectifs en 2024
va quand même produire ses effets puis
accessoirement j'ai surtout une grande
école qui normalement doit produire des
carrières et des compétences pour se
faire parce que c'est une école
d'ingénieur militaire dont je suis le
ministre de tutelle c'est évidemment
l'École
polytechnique
pardon non pas tous c'est pas vrai euh
ce serait caricatural je veux dire euh
la rité c'est qu'il y a pas suffisamment
de postes au minarme pour tous les
polytechnens qui sortent chaque année ou
même pour la BITD donc ça on peut pas
leur en faire la critique la réalité
c'est que nos écoles doivent aussi
prendre un certain nombre de virages y
compris d'ailleurs les écoles de
sous-officiers sur un certain nombre de
fonctions bon là il y a tout un thème
j'ai promis d'être rapide mais en tout
cas il est clair qu'il faut qu'il faut
avancer et je rajouterai un troisième
combat c'est de la souplesse dans la
gestion parce que bah oui un jeune un
jeune cyber combattant à la DGSE par
définition à 24 ou 25 ans aura un mode
de vie un rapport aux horaires à la nuit
et au jour au weekend et à la semaine
euh qui seront peut-être un peu
différents de certains de des personnels
plus classiques du ministère donc là
aussi j'ai je pense aussi qu'il faut
qu'on se mette à porter deux donc il a
un petit pivot culturel à faire aussi
qu'il faut faire gentiment mais qui est
en train de se faire euh fond sous-marin
bon H8 drones livrés en 2024
monsieurateur gu j'y reviens pas il y a
premier sujet deuxième sujet il faut
qu'on continue avancer sur les brides
techno on revient à l'innovation on
revient aussi à ce que les PME peuvent
peuvent nous apporter la matière trois
il y a les grands programmes à effet
majeur guerre des mines bon c'est un
énorme sujet euh j'ai pas le temps de
tout détailler là j'ai passé un certain
nombre de commandes de réflexion à naal
groupe sur sur ce sujet-là qui est un
sujet absolument clé pour les ports de
Toulon comme de Brest d'ailleurs mais
aussi d'ailleurs d'exploration de son
sous-marin sécurisation des câbles bon
autant de sujets sur lesquels on
pourrait revenir il y a de l'argent dans
la LPM vous l'avez voté il y a de
l'argent dans la LPM pour pour se faire
euh monsieur le F sur l'Ukraine vous
avez raison maintenant faut qu'on arrive
à travailler court terme moyen terme
long terme les trois en même temps parce
que si on fait que du court terme et
c'est ce qu'on a fait sous le coup de
l'urgence c'est bien naturel on n'est
pas en situation de d'offrir des
perspectives à l'armée ukrainienne y
compris en matière de capacité à
dissuader à se protéger et de capacité
aussi pour l'armée ukrainienne de se
projeter vous la connaissez bien vous
l'avez suffisamment côtoyé visité ils
vous le disent nos industriels vont
aussi apporter des solutions de court
terme la nouveauté c'est c'est que
l'Ukraine aussi a décidé de se doter de
fonds souverains qui d'ailleurs
largement ét alimenté par des
confiscations d'avoir russes qui leur
permettent d'acheter ça c'est aussi une
nouveauté et le nouveau ministre de la
Défense ukrainien d'ailleurs a développé
cette nouvelle stratégie devant
justement nos industriel l'autre jour et
devant un certain nombre d'industriel du
monde entier et typiquement l'armée
ukrainienne enfin le ministère de la
Défense ukrainien a signé un accord
d'acquisition de six canons César et là
en fait vous me voyez reconnecter tous
les combats entre eux notre combat sur
l'économie de G commence à porter ses
fruits puisque jadis il fallait 30 mois
pour produire un canon César désormais
il en faut 17 on a les premiers canon
César d'ailleurs monsieur le Président
qui ont été validés enfin don les tirs
ont été homologués par la DGA qui vont
nous permettre de d'une part recompléter
les forces qui s'étaient vu prélever euh
ces canons en session direct pour
l'Ukraine et en même temps pouvoir
permettre à Nexter par les licences
d'exportation de commencer à en vendre
euh à à à l'Ukraine ou à d'autres pays
qui pourront donner à l'Ukraine donc là
on commence à avoir un agenda court
moyen long terme là vous avez raison sur
pieds détachés et munition il est clair
qu'on est toujours sur de la session de
court terme au but en 55 mm pour prendre
l'exemple le plus le plus le plus fameux
les amxc le président en a parlé hier
soir au micro de Caroline rou je crois
au moins que nous avons fa effet de
levier pour d'autres coalitions de char
et ça au moins mérite mais vous étiez
dans la confidence de cette affaire
monsieur le ministre le moine sur le
plan famille donc de fait il y a un
enjeu de déconcentration de cette
affaire moi je souite que pour 2024
chaque chef de corps commandant de base
aérienne base navale puisse avoir une
enveloppe à sa main pour un certain
nombre de petits travaux euh qui sont en
lien parfois avec la condition du
militaire au quotidien on a fait une
opération poignée de porte comme le
ministère de l'Intérieur l'avait fait
aussi pour le ministère des armées ça
peut être vrai également pour les petits
travaux en lien avec les collectivités
territoriales je vous donner un chiffre
mais il vaut ce qu'il vaut parce que en
fonction de la taille des emprises ça
peut varier mais l'idée c'est que chaque
chef de corps au moins une enveloppe de
50000 € pour pouvoir faire des petites
choses et ça c'est le début d'une
culture euh s parler de de de
jacobinisme enfin il a quand même aussi
ses limites euh c'est la limite c'est le
bon sens euh et de qu'un colonel plein
chef de corps euh d'un régiment ou
comment une base aérienne soit obligé de
demander l'autorisation à 36 personnes
pour engager des choses qui sont hyper
simple en matière d'infra euh dans son
unité objectivement ça n'a pas de sens
ça c'est du mauvais jacobinisme pour le
coup et donc évidemment c'est un choc de
simplification que j'appelle bien pris
sur IgA j'aurai des décisions à prendre
en plus prochainement sur la gouvernance
de l'IGA donc message bien reçu
quantique bon c'est un sujet clé euh
vous aviez d'ailleurs dans vos fonctions
précédentes suivi aussi ces affaires
puisque en lien avec le plan de relance
il a aussi évidemment des des choses qui
peuvent être mutualisées au sein de
l'État en interministériel et il y a
évidemment du quantique militaire pur
pur alors soit parce que en lien avec
l'activité opérationnelle avec des
enjeux de de cryptage bon donc ça pose
la question de d'acquérir là aussi les
blocs de compétences qui vont bien
notamment sur ce qui peut-être un
ordinateur quantique dans dans les temps
qui viendront c'est la DGA évidemment
qui est chef de fil de cette affaire là
et a de l'argent qui est mis sur la
table pour le coup le déjà vous
auditionnerez pour répondre à vos
questions précisément parce que ça fait
partie de sa feuille de de route et
c'est un peu pour ça qu'il a été nommé
pour être complètement transparent avec
vous c'est justement pour faire le pivot
sur ces nouvelles sur ces nouvelles
technologies euh il y a des usages aussi
mais comme pour lia d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant cartographie des océans
enfin y a des objets qui sont qui sont
voilà sur une audition qui retransmise
donc j'irai pas plus loin mais sur de la
vie opérationnelle très concrète sans
parler de les applications en matière de
renseignement ou même de disfusion
nucléaire il a des choses évidemment
très importantes à attendre du quantique
en matière militaire dans des temps qui
peuvent être plus proches qu'on le croit
euh me semble-t-il mais ça va aussi
demander un effort sur formation
savoir-faire fidélisation des des
sachants là évidemment il y a un point
et je revois ce que j'ai dit aussi sur
l'École polytechnique pour aussi former
euh les cerveaux de demain sur sur ces
sujets
euh alors sur la question à portée
générale je l'ai dit nombreusespr
pendant la discussion de LPM faut aussi
comparer nos diplomaties il se trouve
que la République française n'entend
envahir personne ce qui quand même déjà
conditionne beaucoup notre format
d'armée non mais c'est je je je le dis
toujours mais vous savez j'interviens
souvent devant des des sing Tang des
scolaires des universités et cetera et
c'est vrai que comparer des budgets de
pays qui ont par définition diplomatie
d'agression euh ou d'expansion et non
respect du droit international c'est pas
complètement pareil que de comparer un
pays qui par définition a une doctrine
une diplomatie on peu plus claire
deuxième des choses c'est très compliqué
de comparer et compris le budget de
voisin entre nous je vois bien ce que la
certaine presse veut faire en nous
comparant avec
l'Allemagne pardon enfin la culture
expéditionnaire est pas la même
puissance deté pas puissance dotée c'est
pas la même chose outreem ou pas outreem
avec les zones économiques exclusives
qui vont vont avec et qui donc par
définition définissent c'estur folio que
c'est son c'est un cheval de bataille
par définition quand on a des
territoires ultraamarins on a un enjeu
évidemment de souveraineté et de
sécurité évidemment des populations que
la tyrannie des distances depuis Paris
doit permettre de de traiter donc en
fait c'est très compliqué de comparer
les budgets de défense entre eux et
c'est pour ça que j'avais eu ce débat
avec un certain nombre d'entre vous je
je moi-même je ne suis pas accrocher au
2 % du PIB en tant que tel on les fera
donc ça me permet jeis le minist des
armées qui va nous permettre de le
refaire donc je je peux en parler
tranquillement mais au fond c'est
surtout ce qu'on en fait et donc c'est
surtout les contrats opérationnels que
l'on veut avoir qui permettent de
définir derrière des grandes armées avec
des hangars remplis de matériel qui ne
servent jamais il y en a il y en a et
vous avez on le voit bien des structures
beaucoup plus petites moins bien dotées
avec de petits budgets qui représentent
pour le coup des menaces très
importantes donc l'affaire des
comparaisons budgétaires méritent d'être
challengé avec d'autres d'autres intrans
en tout cas dans dans l'équation
et au-delà de l'argent je l'avais dit
avec un peu de gravité dans une émission
récente mais vous avez les pays qui ont
encore des armées d'emploi c'est-à-dire
en clair pas qu'entraîner mais dont on
accepte aussi la blessure et la
mort c'est notre modèle assurément quel
que soit nos divergences politiques ici
c'est notre modèle c'est pas le vrai
d'autres modèles donc la l'équipement
les points de PIB les tableaux
capacitaires sont très importants enfin
à côté il y a aussi est-ce qu'on est
vraiment prêt à à accepter justement la
la mort et la blessure dans notre
société de celles et ceux qui portent
l'uniforme pour une cause notre sécurité
mais aussi parfois des causes qui nous
dépassent la sécurité d'alliés ou d'amis
c'est ce qui nous est arrivé au Sahel
voilà donc ça je pense aussi que je le
livre ici devant la commission ad hoc
c'est un des points aussi sur lequel il
faut qu'on resensibilise notre opinion
publique parce que ça ne seéit pas le
jour où c'est disparu cette affaire
c'est c'est une culture ça s'appelle le
patriotisme ça ça du prix pardonnez-moi
moi dernière des dernières questions
bien double usage alors c'est Bercy qui
est compétent sur les bien double usage
donc moi je sais pas vous répondre donc
faut je les renvoie vers eux sans bter
en touche après sur le fond moi je vous
l'ai dit je suis disponible pour mener
l'audition sur les exportations d'armes
de manière globale avec les ministres de
Bercy compétent sur les biens à double
usage avec les ministres du pôle
Affaires étrangères compétent évidemment
sur les des aspects plus diplomatiques
donc c'est une affaire d'agenda mais
elle a eu lieu par deux fois à
l'Assemblée elle pas eu lieu au Sénat
donc moi je redire vraiment je je veux
que ça ait lieu c'est très important
dans les engagements qui ont été donnés
au Parlement
euh je me serai toujours à disposition
du sénateur Casabon pour sa girond
natal et pour le sénateur Ludovic et bon
le spatial est un des gros patchs aussi
pivot de la de la LPM avec d'ailleurs la
particularité que pendant longtemps on
avait les lanceurs
et il y avait pas forcément beaucoup de
d'expression de besoin ou de commande
militaire et là au final on va avoir un
gros gros carnet de commande le
ministère des armées va être un gros
Grou acheteur de solutions
spatial depuis l'espace dans l'espace
ENF je vi pas surt ce que j'ai
longuement décrit pendant la
programmation militaire et évidemment il
y a le sujet du calendrier d'Arian 6 sur
lequel plutôt elle sera prête mieux ce
sera merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci pour ses réponses je pas terminer
mes chers collègues j'ai encore quelques
annonces paroiales je rends l'antenne
comme on dit et puis vous me direz quand
ce sera fait